I heard something funny the EU needs to
flatten the curve so they're limiting
electricity which is what yeah and then
when I heard them say they were
flattening the curve by doing this I'm
like oh so that whole thing was like
training people and then when you look
at how things are going with you know
the cult and how they follow the media
it's like yeah people are trained they
are and then I started thinking about
this I'm like if they're reusing this
terminology in a new way to reduce
energy this was completely predicted by
tons of people that the next move was
going to be locking down for climate
change and love lo and behold we're
getting something akin to that surprise
surprise ladies and gentlemen we're in
the rat hope experiment they put us in
the cylinder we swam and struggled they
took us out dried us off put it back in
now they expect us to swim twice as long
I think I think it's gonna get a whole
lot worse the only difference between
the rat hope experiment and what we're
going through is that we have an
election coming up and we might get new
leaders who say no to all of this so it
should be interesting so we're going to
talk about that plus the riots and
protests that are erupting because of
the energy crisis California facing
rolling blackouts well good for them
Gavin Newsom was seen wearing a sweater
amid a record Heat Wave and a lot of
people are like what is he doing yeah
he's probably blasting the AC while
telling you to suffer ain't that how it
works and then we have this uh story
AOC gave an interview where she said she
doesn't know if she'll be alive by
September now of course she gave the
interview a little while ago so I don't
know why she thought by now she'd be
dead I'm glad she's not you know I hope
she lives a long and prosperous life but
I have to wonder first does she have
cancer and then I thought oh she's
talking about like Civil War or
something hot drink yeah she's talking
about something like that I guess
patriarchy and how people hate women of
color and then she thought she'd be dead
by now so either they're completely
overreacting or you look at everything
that's going on it's kind of falling
apart so we're going to talk about that
and more before we get started my
friends head over to eat right and
feelwell.com to pick up your keto
Elevate powder from BioTrust 51 off if
you go there today this is C8 MCT oil
powder that's medium chain triglyceride
if you are wondering how I shed all of
this weight over the past year and I did
I was looking at a video from January
and I was like wow I lost a lot of
weight um I've been doing keto cut out
most sugars doing like a modified low
carb thing now but this stuff really
does help I load it into my coffee
go to eat rightandfillwell.com you'll
get a 60 day money money back guarantee
keto Elevate provides your body only C8
to the most ketogenic MCT five grams of
the highly sought after mctc8 per scoop
keto Elevate personally it is my
favorite medium chain triglycer
triglyceride powder on the market today
you'll get free shipping on every order
and forever for every order today
BioTrust donates a nutritious meal to a
hungry child in your honor through their
partnership with no kidhungry.org to
date BioTrust has provided over 5
million meals to Hungry kids please help
them hit their goal of 6 million meals
this year you'll get free VIP live
health and fitness coaching from
BioTrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
and their free or e-report the top 14
ketogenic foods with every order again
EatRight and feelwell.com thank you very
much much BioTrust for supporting us and
don't forget to head over to timcast.com
become a member to support us directly
and we're going to have a members only
uncensored show coming up at 11 PM
tonight you don't want to miss it
they're good fun and I also recommend
checking out the cast Castle Vlog
starring Ian Crossland for president oh
it's loaded with jokes it's the longest
one we've done yet it's one of the
funniest my favorite bit was the Roberto
Junior bit with James Lindsay check that
one out smash the like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends joining us to talk about all of
this is Amala epinobi did I get it you
got it I got it you got it you're one of
the first people to actually get my name
right on the first try I was worried
great job thank you now I feel good the
K is silent okay silent that's the
tricky part who are you I am omelette
bonobi 22 years old I'm currently
working over at prageru as a personality
whatever that means you guys can decide
whether or not I actually have one uh
yes and I am a recent radical leftist
who sort of left the left and on sort of
the other side of things now yeah if you
want you can move that mic around with
you and just keep it like about this
aiming right at your face beautiful yeah
got it yeah momentous beautiful yes
yeah we're checking the audio right now
no worries just uh what happened was the
digital gain was erased oh yeah so
that's why those audio problems digital
game digital it's like it's like a band
name I feel like I work on a spaceship
sometimes I know but any of this means
yeah it's exciting tell me about
yourself
I'm a writer for timcast.com it's a
super cool new site I think everyone
should check it out every day what kind
of things do you write uh I write all
kinds of things I was talking about
Michigan's uh abortion ban today or the
judge's ruling on their abortion law I
wrote about Vladimir Putin earlier today
always interesting yeah we cover a lot
of stuff lots of science lots of policy
and I again highly recommend timcast.com
to absolutely everyone there you go all
right well hey I'm Ian Crossland good to
see you guys Amala great to meet you
good to be here and I just want to
remind you check out Cass Castle it's
it's really hot go to timcast.com sign
up if you want to see the episode
episode from yesterday I'm very pleased
with my work and the work of the cast
people are their acting skills are I
mean you can tell it's like we're rising
up it's getting hot it's getting good
and the texts coming together too it's
turning into a real TV show and Crush
that like button get ready that's right
I'm very excited for all this new stuff
coming out we're going to be adjusting
the audio as we go on the fly like we do
I'm stoked to get in today's stories
though if we're ready to go are we ready
all right check out this first story
from timcast.com EU to impose mandatory
electricity cuts to flatten the curve
reduced reduce Peak energy demands
European commission had announced as
Russian price gaps as Putin threatens to
cut Europe off from all energy
deliveries the European Union has
announced plans for mandatory
electricity rationing with European
commission president Ursula Vander layen
telling reporters the EU must flatten
the curve of peak Energy prices
her announcement highlighted a
five-point plan the EU is preparing to
enact to address local energy markets
Europe has faced an energy crisis
following Russia cutting off supplies of
natural gas the funny thing is Russia is
now selling gas to China who's driving
it all the way back to Europe and crank
you know cranking up the cost and now
people are looking at like 500 energy
increases Italy you've got bars and
restaurants with candles and uh when you
look over at California and they're
doing the exact same thing it kind of
feels like what's happening there is
going to happen here and we're just a
little bit behind but I know Amela you
live in California right how's that yeah
unfortunately I do live in Los Angeles
so last night I was chilling in my
apartment and got a notification that
says you know due to our overwhelmed
electrical grid your electricity might
go out at any moment and you're gonna
have to deal with that for an hour or
two we'll rotate it across rotate it
across our different circuits and uh
welcome to the new world order here but
it didn't your power didn't go out it
didn't end up going out but uh I guess
they're putting out warnings that
through this continuous heat wave that
we're going through right now that
there's a very good possibility that's
going to happen and in other regions of
California they're doing those rotating
brownouts yeah you saw you saw Gavin
Newsom though right yes sweater that was
awesome yeah he's cold okay maybe he's
like a you know it could be that he's a
lizard person you know and then it's
like it may be hot but yes it still
needs to I like that he's got like
really crazy tattoos of late yeah
he rips his sleeves off and he's just
got sleeves Yeah so basically after 4 pm
I heard Gavin doing did a video maybe
this is a video You're referencing after
4 P.M that's like hot time that's like
Peak Peak electricity turn off your what
everything except for your large
appliances yeah they're saying basically
try not to use AC if you can help it
cool your house or your apartment
beforehand don't turn on any larger
major appliances anything like that and
certainly don't charge your electric
cars even though we're gonna start
Banning gas vehicles in the coming years
have you heard of passive cooling have
you ever studied any of that stuff no
they make like these uh I don't know if
they're made out of wood or out of cork
and then they'll like make all these
little like cuts through the Cork and
then you just pour water into the Cork
and then through it only works in really
dry environments okay but through
um I don't know evaporation yeah
evaporation it cools down the room by
like depends the water absorbs the heat
from the atmosphere to it'll get you
from like 105 to 90 maybe you know it's
for desperate hot dry climate does we
spit in a studio apartment that's the
question yeah it's a little box we'll
probably make one from cardboard they
have a creative low energy evaporation
uh air conditioners you fill them with
water and then it basically yeah
recently just bought one of those
although I don't know after 4 pm if we
can even have those on you know here's a
question why don't you leave Los Angeles
oh you're getting into tricky territory
here so I do work for Prager you were
headquartered in Los Angeles Dennis's
fault you know Dennis who you had on the
show he's like I am not leaving
California he's like I'm I'm perfectly
fine being in California and I get it
he's also wearing a sweater
Dennis is chilling Dennis is chilling
and yeah you know I will say that being
in the heart of all the problems does
really get you invigorated every day to
be in the fight you know when you're
walking out of your apartment and a
homeless man screams obscenities at you
you're ready to work every single day
that's fair I feel like to learn how you
got to learn self-defense yeah you've
also got to learn you know uh tactical
poop cleanup you know I don't know if
you're gonna step in it I'm 120 pounds
soaking wet so uh self-defense is
something I need to work on 100 yeah Jiu
Jitsu yeah where were you before La
Florida oh wow yeah you know what I like
to think I thought it through
it was a fantastic opportunity I love my
job so much so it's totally worth it
don't get me wrong but leaving the
freedom State of Florida to go to La
which has just been disintegrating in
front of my eyes has been an interesting
you're on the front lines on the front
line you left the Comfort I'm just
imagining you you're like you're at home
in Florida and you tell your family and
you like salute them and you're like I'm
going to the front line no I don't
you're crazy and I'm going and then you
go to California it's really bad which
it's hilarious because my mom is a super
radical left-leaning person so she would
love to have switched from Florida to
move over to Los Angeles and we've sort
of taken our opposite path your mom is
radical left because you said you were
too right I was too yeah did you
appreciate Florida while you were there
no this place is awful it's like I hate
this place did you did you get like hit
in the head with a turtle shell or
something and it just knocks sense into
you or what happened you know what so I
grew up my mom works for the political
left hi Mom she's not watching but
definitely not watching uh so I grew up
with her influence and I I was
constantly told about the oppression
that I was going to face Living in
America she happens to be white so she
was telling me about like you're you
know you're black it's going to be a
little bit difficult for you things are
going to be hard and I totally fell for
it hook line and sinker graduated high
school started working as a youth
organizer and door knocking and telling
people who they needed to vote for I
worked on the Andrew Gillum campaign in
Florida yeah we all know how that turned
out like luckily my efforts went
unnoticed on that and eventually just
recognize so much hypocrisy that I had
to leave and started looking at other
views what made you realize like what
was the moment that you realized
something yeah so I grew up with my
white family and I was constantly going
to work and hearing about how awful
white people were and there were several
instances where it was just the most
blatant racist rhetoric you could hear
regarding somebody all towards white
people and I would go and work on these
projects and then go home to my white
family that had taken care of me my
entire life and I eventually confronted
one of the VPS at the organization and
said I don't get it man we're we said
we're tolerant we said we're anti-racist
we're literally working on these like
critical race Theory initiatives and he
basically told me you don't know how
oppressed you are and that's not my
fault so so it's like half your family
black half your family white yes I
wonder because I I have a similar
experience I come from a mixed mixed
race family so I'm a quarter I'm a
quarter Asian and my experience was was
similar in that I go out and I hear
these lefties saying things like white
people are bad and I'm like hey wait a
minute like I got white family right and
not white family and I'm pretty sure
you're full of sh you know what I mean
ish yeah yeah like this and then what I
end up actually seeing growing up is the
policies they put in place they claim
help help racism actually just end up
hurting my family and my family was the
epitome of like opposing racism right a
hundred percent I went through the exact
same experience I actually grew up in a
really rural conservative small town
never truly experienced an ounce of
racism in my life but was so dedicated
to the idea that I was oppressed in this
country that I like fought people about
it and I I
basically labeled myself as a victim and
went around the world telling everybody
about how victimized I was but so so
when you go to your family and you're
like hey I don't believe this stuff
because like you know we're a mixed
family and clearly the white people in
my family are good people this is not
true yeah well so my mom and dad got
divorced when I was sick so I was
basically just with my mother's
influence and I went to her and I was
like hey Mom I think I might be a little
conservative and she hated it and we
went through what's the liberal
equivalent of sprinkling you with holy
water yeah
he's like what can I do to stop this
from happening because I was like her
little Protege in a lot of ways working
at the same organization she was working
for so you know her her head blew
through the roof and we went through
months of just contentious arguments
over all these different subject matters
and eventually she was like okay this is
my daughter I think she's pretty
strong-willed about what she believes
right now and I'm just gonna leave it
alone maybe we don't talk politics yeah
I went through something similar with my
mom and I realized after like five or
six years that it was more about the
tone that we were communicating it was
more about you know less about trying to
be right or just listening but he and
red build his mom yeah but it took 12
years and it was like we almost our
relationship almost ended and she got
really sick from stress like it was
horrible when you go at it and you're
like obsessed with trying to convince
someone they can get really really ill
it can really hurt people so the best is
just to exist and listen and the the
cult is scary I agree yeah I realized it
just through living my life with my
values I think it would sort of
influence her a little bit like she's
now come around and said you know what
I'm I think I'm comfortable being
friends with people who are conservative
which for her it's a big great big step
I mean when I say she's radical leftist
I mean as far left as you could possibly
be so yeah but like authoritarian or
libertarian
authoritarian authoritarian because like
the libertarian left in my opinion
doesn't really exist like they do but
it's such an impossible political
standard that most people on the left
abandon it right but then claim their
libertarian left to try and Win Win
votes so they can then enslave you you
know what I mean yeah I mean with all
the policing you want to do of people's
speech and how they act and what they do
it's hard not to be authoritarian in
that sense do you know political Compass
memes there's like a couple different
pages yeah oh is it like the little test
that you take that puts you yeah yeah
the memes are hilarious and it's like
one of the one of the one place on the
internet where they actually understand
what the political Compass actually
means and you'll actually see like the
left and the right arguing with each
other but laughing at these jokes and I
did a I did a mini rant once where I
said
woke people are not libertarian left
every single time people come out and
talk about antifa or something they
claim it's a Libertarian left and I'm
like dude it is not libertarian to go
around bashing people over the skull
demanding they live the way they want
you to live that's authoritarian left
libertarian left is like hippies living
on a farm being like you want to share
this watermelon with me dude the problem
is supporting that is extremely
difficult and it doesn't scale scale
very well but the political Compass
means people were like Tim is correct
and they they put my face on the liberal
left quadrant arguing why antifa and
woke people are not libertarian left and
everybody agreed like all these
different people were like yeah that's
that's literally like woke people are
authoritarian Kami socialist types right
as soon as you start trying to impose
your worldview on anybody you can't call
yourself a Libertarian right that's why
it was really funny when um was it
Jorgensen the libertarian candidate said
yeah Joe jargon said it's not enough to
not be racist we must be actively
anti-racist but I was like the
libertarian candidate telling people
what they must do is deliciously ironic
what is the libertarian version of
wokeness
well what was this ideological yeah so
there's there's no there's no deliberate
uh if you were woke and you were a
Libertarian you'd say something like you
know I think you know critical race
Theory and these things are good how can
we you know work with each other I'm
trying to implement what I agree with
and then they say I disagree with you
and it's like oh okay well we disagree
let's figure out how to live together
see I totally get along with those
people I met I met a communist guy he
did he you know I was in Berkeley he
denounced antifa he said the violence is
wrong they shouldn't be doing that he's
like true communism would be us living
together working together and I was like
oh we're friends I was like bro you can
be a communist I don't care as long as
you're not bashing people over the skull
you know and it really is as simple as
that and they think we're we're far
worse that they make us out to be these
horrible villains but really I'm like
you can believe whatever you want to
believe just please don't come into my
territory and impose it on me right but
that's how a lot of book ideology works
it right needs compliance and it needs
you to agree to be a part of it if
anyone questions it then their system is
broken yep and that's unacceptable
that's what I love about like this weird
world where the mainstream corporate
press calls every single person far
right or right wing and it's like it's
just so weird that every single
ideological Viewpoint is right wing like
all of them if you're a communist and
you're woke you're left
but if you're a communist and you're not
woke you're far right if you're a
socialist
and you're anti-corporate you're far
right Jimmy Dore who's like a socialist
is right wing that that one blew my mind
I'm like okay y'all jump look you want
to come at me and say Tim pulls right
wing whatever I'll bet you can make an
argument about center right or something
even though I'm like in the middle but
Jimmy Dore he's like Universal Health
Care and like all these other left
policies but then he goes the Democrats
and the Republicans are corporatists who
are selling you out not that he's far
right right but they just move the
center to a place where they're like
look all the way over there's extreme
stream far right whereas it wouldn't
have been you know a decade ago two
decades ago we just migrated it so far
that we don't understand where the
middle is at all we just gotta ignore
them yeah I love the buzzwords kind of
kind of let the buzzwords flow through
you the alt the left the right the the
authoritarian the libertarian like you
don't fall into a group like we're not
putting you in a in a in a holding cell
right now because of what label we
slapped on your chest it doesn't that
stuff's not relevant in humanity Jimmy's
a great example of that because he talks
so much you see the intricacies of of
who he is and he doesn't he's way all
over the place as he believes what he
believes right Jimmy has left I just
think we have to ignore what the cult
thinks because the woke cult is not left
or right like this this is what I was
saying people some people don't don't
agree but I'm like
sterilizing your kids is not a left wing
or right-wing position it is of the left
right now but the left is like
it's it's usually a reference to
revolutionary or economically flat
systems communism for instance the
furthest left you go on the political
Compass whereas right is laissez-faire
capitalism those as the economic scale I
think Jimmy is a bit revolutionary he's
got that revolutionary state of mind but
I also I can tell that he appreciates uh
like the state when it functions
properly he likes that kind of stuff and
he's willing to use the state to you
know accommodate people this is and
that's more authoritarian versus
libertarian in the state versus you know
no State and the thing that always
confused me when it was is when they say
like laissez-faire capitalists are far
right and so are Nazis and I'm like but
they completely disagree on like
everything how does that make sense what
does that even mean and they say things
like that they're always trying to
redefine what left and right is in order
to justify why you are not left or
whatever so I'm just like we got to be
careful about putting people in camps
that's what that is is the first step on
the path to putting people in camps is
giving them labels and putting them in a
Consciousness box when it comes to I
think Colt is often a good word I know
it's a strong word but it's a good word
because as soon as you start to deviate
on even one single issue they throw you
out and label you as something and
language is so powerful for the woke
left in particular the way they
manipulate it the way they utilize it in
order to put people in certain groups
and label them and as soon as we go you
know I'm not going to accept the label
and I'm not going to take that I think
it's when we start changing the game a
little bit you know what what's
interesting is I think it's like the The
Snowball Effect the snowball rolling
down a hill so I'd imagine for you as
for like a lot of people who start
questioning wokeness you probably said
something small like hey I kind of don't
agree with you on the white people thing
and then they immediately start shoving
you as hard as they could out yep that's
exactly what happened I had so I'll tell
a quick little story I was working on a
project called the Groveland four back
in Florida and it was about these four
black men had been wrongfully accused of
sexual assault and there was a
documentary that we were showing and I
was trying to get all these college and
high school kids to come and say you
know this is America this is what they
do to black people they shove them
through the criminal justice system even
when they dub nothing and in the
background round Brett Kavanaugh gets
accused of sexual assault and that whole
Firestorm starts happening and I'm
working on this project watching Brett
Kavanaugh just completely break down on
camera and I brought it to my boss and I
said you know why are we treating these
two situations differently why is he
completely just getting obliterated by
the media and by the work that we're
doing here yet when these four black men
get wrongfully accused we're giving them
all the grace in the world and he said
well he's a white man and I don't care
and he clearly is the frat boy type so
he did it and he should hang wow yeah it
just when I tell you the most dramatic
rhetoric you could possibly hear I was
hearing day in and day out I don't know
how I didn't leave sooner but eventually
it was just you can't stand it I kind of
feel like the left hates mixed race
people like woke people like their their
perspective is
I've experienced this personally where
they're like we should have segregated
spaces right the POC and the non-poc and
then you know if you walk up to them and
you're like what if I'm both they're
like get out because then you're still
white and and your story what I'm
imagining is like you've got white
family him saying he's white I don't
care let him hang it's like yo you
realize like when people say it's up to
me I'm like imagining my family I'm like
I don't like that right like you're
talking about my family too which was
interesting because I had conservative
people in my family who are sort of like
the Fox News conservatives watching that
all the time and then I had my mom who
was totally on board of you know F white
people and I'm I just happen to be a
white Ally but also I'm part of the
problem so my brain was just going crazy
all throughout my childhood did you feel
like she owed you an explanation did it
like hurt your sense of identity you
know I I just have conversations with
her now and say you know in the future
maybe we don't do this to Children maybe
we don't teach them that they're victims
from like the age of eight years old and
and you know tell them that there's some
Boogeyman not to get them but he's
invisible and see how that goes and how
did other people in your community react
when you were like I don't know that I
totally get behind all these beliefs
anymore I was completely just ousted
from the organization gone left never
talked to again and of course later I
about a year or so later I started
making videos and and those sort of blew
up and just people were pissed one story
I talk about Iris often is that during
Occupy Wall Street there was this dude I
was a white dude a black dude and uh
black dude was like I'm gonna run across
the street to go to the bathroom and the
white dude they were friends he was like
oh hey would you grab me a cheeseburger
when you're over there and the black
dude went off and he was like excuse me
and he was and he was like oh can you
grab me a cheeseburger when you're over
there I'll give you money and the black
dude just went off and started yelling
at him and then I asked him later what
happened and then he he said you see how
racist that was and then I was like he
asked you to get him a cheeseburger and
he's like yeah like I'm his boy like
going to get him food or something and I
was like dude my friends asked me to
grab them stuff from the store all the
time
you fly I'll buy that's what we use Taco
Bell what I think happened there was
that
this dude internalizes the racism and
sees everything through a lens of their
you're being racist towards me so
something as simple as my friend asked
me to grab him food because I was
already going that way
turns into a racist attack on him yeah
absolutely well and I think white guilt
is something that people are introduced
to at a really young age I saw a friend
over the weekend and she's moved to New
City and she told me that she
specifically picked her yoga studio
because it was in the historically black
neighborhood and she liked that it was
owned by a woman of color and if that's
your preference totally cool and then
she said I also think it's really
important that they offer classes for
free to black people only and they think
it's better because I should be paying
for it it's okay if I have to pay and
other people don't and I was like you're
describing discrimination you know that
right but it's you know what am I
supposed to say to someone who feel
feels like this is part of her moral
duty to the world like you were saying
kind of approach it calmly this is what
I think people who agree with us need to
understand there's no mistake they're
racist they they Define racist in a
different way but who cares the way they
look I'm not trying to win an argument
with them over what words mean to me my
basis for racism is that they want
racial discrimination that they believe
certain races are inherently one way or
another or something like that whereas
I'm kind of like yo if I went to a
restaurant and they they had signs about
like only serving white people or
somebody said to me that they were that
that they liked a restaurant because it
catered to white people and offered free
food to white people I'd be like that's
kind of messed up I don't like that and
if they did the same thing for Mexicans
or black people I'd be like that's not
okay I don't like that that's kind of
lame
and the woke
they want the segregation yeah like the
it's fascinating when I talk to people
and tell them about how Dearborn
Michigan had the do you see this one the
POC and the nonpoc digital events they
did I've seen a lot of places doing this
tons of this stuff and they're like it's
a good thing and I'm like it's a bad
thing I'm like well if you don't like it
you're racist then I'm like dude I don't
care what word you use I don't like what
you're doing and I'm just going to stay
away from you and that's the smart thing
to do I mean you know ibrahamex Candy
who we all know and dislike talks about
you know the way to fix past
discrimination is present discrimination
and how that lands with anybody I just
don't understand and I think a quick
thought exercise that anybody can do is
to sort of look at these headlines and
what these will people are doing and
swap out people of color or black or
Hispanic for for any other race and and
see how you feel about it see if it's
truly racist and it always is yeah it
always is yeah it's crazy I think part
of it is people feel like they are
um
they are doing the right thing by making
things by overcompensating you know by
saying like oh well we'll we'll pay more
now because at the time you were wronged
and I think we forget that we can
acknowledge that past wrongs were
committed without needing to you know
push a bunch of other people down in
order to make this unstable system we're
trying to build up on it doesn't make
any sense isn't it funny though how
there's an overlap between these people
they're the same people who support war
with Ukraine they're the same people who
think everybody should bend the knee to
vaccine mandates like what's what's up
with that I think it's because
you know I was thinking about the these
I saw these memes about how the
Christian right were mean and they hated
people and I'm like yeah that's not been
my experience you know for the most part
but I wonder because because I know that
they exist and I wonder if what what it
really is is that there are a group of
people
that or I would say a certain amount of
people tend to be zealous and mob-like
they don't actually believe anything
they just do whatever the dominant
social group says and they adhere to it
with with force and aggression and at
one point when the when when this
country was dominated by Christians
those people claim to be Christians a
game a bad name now that the country is
moving towards secularism these people
are now the same people they've always
been but now just along with the woke
giving them a bad name and making them
look like garbage but the problem is
they're The prominent ones that are
pushing the stuff obviously there's like
regular people who are like on the left
I think racism is bad but the dominant
voices have all become these like
Despicable weird authoritarians and I
think they make it so
um such a gray area where it's like well
you your instincts on what is racism
what feels wrong to you is wrong you
don't have a true understanding of this
because you don't have this knowledge
and context that we especially in the
realm of Academia say You must
understand and go through to really get
yeah and I think another underlying
factor with why they do things like the
vaccine mandates and jumping into war
with Ukraine when I was working for the
left there was this constant idea of
radical compassion so you identify a
problem you identify what you think
would be the compassionate thing to do
and you do that to the most radical
extent that you possibly can which means
hopping into war with Russia which means
mandating vaccines for everybody if
you're if you want people to be able to
come into the United States and
immigrate here we need open borders
everything is always the most radical
form of policy they can think of you
know radical compassion doesn't work in
my opinion I tried it in 2006 on
internet videos it's like what would
Jesus do with this technology he'd
connect with everyone he could and ex
you know spread the gospel listen to
them connect with their eyes and I was
doing it and it became so exhausting and
a lot of very weak people would would
connect with me and I was like I'm not
turning anyone away I'll talk to anybody
and so it broke me like the the the
people that were busted up
psychologically were infecting my mind
with busted up psychology and I was
becoming busted up and I realized it's
not sustainable this radical you you
need to let people fix themselves you
need to maybe create an environment
where it's easier for them some people
can't be fixed but that's up to them
people I cannot fix them I can only give
them an opportunity to fix themselves
it's coddling it's what's happening
right now and that's what I recognized a
lot when talking about being biracial in
America so much as what do we need to do
for you what's hard for you how can you
get into school how can you get a job
and you can switch out the race thing
for for gender or sexuality but that's
constantly the underlying factor is how
can I be a savior towards ex-community
it's funny that I I think there are
different conspiracy theory theorists
factions that
all will blame one group of people for
their problems so like you've got uh the
groups that's you know supposed to be
like the globalists you know you know
the more Alex Jones oriented conspiracy
theory types not referring to him
specifically but you've got people who
hate Jewish people and blame them for
all the problems you've got the woke who
blame white people for other problems
you've got to occupy while she blames
the one percent for all their problems
it's like if you want to figure out
where you fit in which group do you hate
the most blame for all the problems and
you found your friends
to me it's creepy because obviously this
this planet and Society is extremely
nuanced and it's not so simple to say
there's one group that's causing all the
problems there aren't there's like
there's war there's countries there's
cultures there are ideologies within
countries and within races there's
different ideologies that are attacking
each other
but of course the woke they've become
the corporate dominant and they blame
white people for their problems
our minds are so simplistic I mean it's
so weird that we've reduced ourselves
down to things like race and gender
which are just things you can see to the
human eye and then we've just decided oh
because I can see it that must be the
rule of thumb here and there must be one
ultimate villain in every single case
for every single problem it's
unbelievable how simplistic our brains
work I don't like the black and white
thing because we're not black and white
that's very obviously a wrong way to
describe things it's too simple it
doesn't function it is let's jump to
this uh good fun story we have here from
the New York Post Kathy Griffin slammed
for saying Republicans will start a
Civil War the first thing I want to say
is she stole your line no no no
hold on New York Post you need this
issue a correction she did not say
Republicans will start a civil war she
never said that that is defamation and
slander of our good friend Kathy what
she said was if you don't want a civil
war vote for Democrats in November if
you do want Civil War vote Republican
she did not say in any capacity the
Republicans would start one in fact she
didn't she didn't in any way imply
either well she didn't State either side
would but she implied Democrats would
let's do some basic logic real quick
if you vote for Democrats they win there
won't be a civil war that means
Republicans will do nothing
if you vote for republicans and they win
and she says there will be a Civil War
in that capacity well Republicans aren't
going to start a civil war after a
winning legitimate power yeah the
Democrats would have to start fighting
with them otherwise they're in power
she's actually implying Democrats will
start a civil war many people pointed
this out she's basically issuing a
threat if you don't vote for us we are
going to war
well and Twitter's cool with it civil
war drink yeah leave it up this is the
second one she did the cut the the Trump
head I think it's gonna held that bloody
head this is kind of another weird like
uh visceral
statement it's just shock value I think
after that Trump head thing she should
just went you know what no more no more
internet for me yeah I think I'm done I
think there's a list yeah take her phone
away seriously I saw her try to work it
back and say you know if the Democrats
are in power they'll be able to hold off
the Maga Republicans from starting some
sort of War that's what I meant by the
Tweet but I don't think that ended so so
she's implying that the the Maga
Republicans get elected are handed the
keys to the castle and then they're
gonna go they just start running around
and smashing things they have legitimate
power they've won an election why would
they do anything like that they're all
crazy white people Tim we don't know
what they're gonna do you don't know
what white people are well that's true
but then you end up with people like Tim
Scott they act like doesn't exist you
know what I mean
yeah I wonder how much of of Kathy is
getting taken out of context because
it's did she say this verbally or was
this in text
she's a comedian texting your your jokes
don't always translate I don't think
this is a joke I mean it does seem like
a cry for attention she didn't have that
reality TV show that was like uh my life
as a d-list celebrity or something oh
yeah yeah this is way back in the dealer
celebrity so I've never heard of it so
herself you know she really does need
people to notice her whenever whenever
possible so I feel like again she's
somewhat political openly a lot of time
but also you know she has to stay part
of the relevant conversation as somebody
who who's you know half of their tweets
are completely nonsensical and hilarious
uh yes I'm saying my jokes are funny uh
I feel for Kathy Griffin if she's taken
out of context the only issue is she she
took a photo of herself holding a faux
severed head of Donald Trump it's hard
to get out of context yeah she's she's
literal like you know look I think my
tweets are funny because I'm
intentionally trolling and screwing
around and the fact that some people
believe so I'll tell you this I tweeted
when the left was ragging on the song we
put out I said the success of only ever
wanted proves that deep down Americans
crave powerful Emo music
but the globalist corporate Elite are
conspiring to suppress it and they
started they started sharing the tweet
on Reddit and other posts being like Tim
Poole literally thinks this and I'm like
that was so overt and it's nonsense that
no sane person would believe I was being
telling the truth if you were to look at
Kathy Griffin is saying and you think
she's joking then I think you're being
equally dishonest I think this is the
this year's Democrats get out the vote
campaign like if you don't vote for us
it's going to end in Civil War and they
want you to believe it's Republicans but
as soon as completely right and pointing
out it's actually the Democrats being
like we will Riot we've been doing it
for a little while here everyone's cool
when we do it not when any Republicans
do it you know it's it's kind of crazy
that she can post this it can stay up
and she's gonna be like no I'm in the
right to say it this is a get out the
vote it's all fear tactics I mean she
seems clearly inspired by Joe Biden we
watched his last speech where he's
talking about you know the mega
Republicans or the threat to America so
we all have to worry about they hate
this country so long as they don't win I
think they're really just pushing fear
fear fear and please get out and vote
for us or else and it works yep it it
works and you know
a lot of Republicans are like oh it's
going to be a red tsunami we're going to
win and I'm like yeah you better operate
under the assumption it's going to be a
blue wave and get out every single
person you can because I'll tell you
even if you do win the likelihood the
Republicans you know the Republican
leadership will do something is low so
you need to make sure the win is
overwhelming so that yeah look if if in
swing States you get moderate
Republicans who win then they're going
to jam things up and be like no no now
listen you know we got to be we can't
play that way we have Rick Santorum on
and you know I respect the guy but he
was like we can't play that game we got
to play by the rules and I'm like oh
okay like dude I get it played by the
rules but playing by the rules also
means you subpoena them when they do
something illegal you don't say well you
know that's too much and too far well
that's what they're doing they're going
after Trump they're going after ban and
they're going after people on the right
they put Peter Navarro in shackles so
maybe Republicans need to win and just
you know get some subpoenas and do some
investigations figure out what went on
with with Crossfire hurricane maybe get
some accountability for Russia gate yeah
and I think if you are conservative
leaning voter it's much better to look
at the tsunami after it's hit then
you'll be like I think it's coming yes
I'll just pretend like and then it turns
out it's nothing there is I think the
Republican party is prone to complacency
and you know they think they're being
forgiving be like well we're not going
to follow up on any of these things we
could press charges but you know we're
going to be the bigger people and move
on and it's like no actually you're
letting the justice system Fall by the
wayside by being inactive and becoming
complacent yeah the Riots of 2020 was an
example of that like day two where was
the National Guard and all they said was
like well if we if we start Prosecuting
people probably get worse right we're
being mean we're just reactionary and
just reactive we're like waiting for
them to come to our backyard to react to
them and then going oh well there was no
laws to protect me for this oh so sorry
so I get called a black pillar a lot
because I'm constantly like hey guys I'm
I'm not convinced there's gonna be a red
wave and they're like oh just let it
happen I'm like no you can't do that way
you need to be taking every single
possible step you can you need to be
getting other people involved in voting
and I've been going back and forth a lot
of people about whether we should fight
on the their level and I think the
ultimate answer is that yes we should as
far as lawfare goes then as far as like
character goes we need to stick by see
that's where your conservative
principles can actually come out is in
your character you don't need to do what
they do you don't need to cancel people
as hard as they do but you can fight
back on the level playing Ground that is
supposedly there was a pull from the uh
Trafalgar group I think today that said
after Biden's speech a lot of
Independence and I can't remember the
percentage but let's say 30 percent
swung and we're like this that's beaches
that's not cool aggressive rhetoric this
is uh inappropriate like this is not
right obviously you know high percentage
Democrats thought that speech was
wonderful lots of conservatives were
like Wait no that's insane but it was
The Independents who are like you're
losing us here Joe Biden Administration
the Democratic party like this is not
something that we support I think it was
like uh I should say the number in front
of me like 50 were like
we are against how this presentation and
the way this looks I think in some ways
the Democrats themselves will show are
showing their true colors but I can't
stress enough that I feel like the
Republican party's one of their biggest
issues is that they become complacent
they're like got in the bag let's all
just pack up and go home and that's how
you lose no we need serious asymmetric
uh what would you call it I guess
culture Warfare yeah well law fair I'm
open to being equal we should be
treating the law equally among all
people but if you want to win a culture
war against a communist infusion or
whatever the hell is happening you need
deep spiritual power you need some sort
of imbalance of power to win that and
that I think is internal it's it's
meditation Consciousness uh listening to
people being willing to cry that comes
out the way that we communicate is so
different to the way that progressives
communicate and I've learned that a lot
just being having worked on both sides
they're Grassroots organizing Endeavors
are insane and they're very well run
they're they're in the communities
running around knocking doors having
conversations with people and having
very emotional conversations with people
and I think that's what influences
voters because conservatives were not
very emotional we don't use like a
storyline in order to to influence
people and as far as his speech he had
an amazing opportunity to hop up there
and give a message of unity and say you
know we can co-exist there is a way that
we can unite out of this and I want to
be the president who does that but he
fumbled the ball and at least that ball
is now in our court yeah I think the
play was you're gonna fumble the other
team's gonna but then we're gonna
recover it and run it in for a touch
like it was like in the speech was
written as a fumble see I feel like it
wasn't actually about Unity because of
the lines about the right wing it was
not he was like under the guise of
patriotism being like look I'm in front
of Independence Hall and they've got all
these great colors and look at those
Marines and then it's like but remember
the modern conservatives are the devil
and if you vote for them you are going
to set our country on fire the emotions
I'm not a uni unifying message the
emotion thing is everything yes right
now the Democrats are heavily just
targeting emotions hate and fear hate
and fear and I think people on the right
as you were mentioning they're not very
emotional they don't get it Ben Shapiro
you know things will make a logical
argument and convince convince you but
in fact he's only speaking to people who
are already logical and people who are
already logical are probably already
more right-leaning so I know this from
having done uh Street fundraising and
I'm canvassing where we would go and
talk to people on the street wave high
they always give you these spiels and
they would be like say this and they
were very methodic logical hi my name is
this I work for here here's a problem we
Face here's how you can help great and
of course that stuff never works and
they don't want you to say anything else
like for like legal reasons but I was
like dude I can get people to sign up
for anything without saying a single
fact like they're worried about you
saying something factually incorrect and
then giving someone someone gives a
donation and then you've got like a you
know liability issue or something and
I'm like just talk on their hard strings
just you know so the pitches I would do
were often very much like trying to make
people cry just like tell them a story
about a you know
talking about homeless people telling
them a story about a homeless person
that no one loves imagine what it must
feel like that no one's there for you
and no one loves you and then when you
finally do see someone walking on the
street they look at you with disgust and
they spit on you and then people are
like feeling bad and then they donate
the best sales pitch I've ever seen was
this guy selling door-to-door children's
encyclopedias I was like yeah I took
this opportunity to be out here because
my fiance's here but you know it's
really hard and they didn't tell you
that their wages would be awful and we
have to buy the product first and like
we like all have to share a van and like
I have to sell these because otherwise
I'm in debt to the company and like I
watch so many people buy that guy's
encyclops you might as well been selling
I don't even know what but if you if you
go up to somebody and say he also may
not have had a fiance
I could have been lying the whole thing
could have been a lie the same is true
for for the right like if you were gonna
make a pitch and say like here's here's
what Democrat policy is bad right Joe
Biden he's enacted these these policies
such as Banning fracking on public lands
which has caused a spike in speculation
now here's a logical reason why that's
gonna they don't don't care they don't
care they say you're lying they say it's
fake news Donald Trump is bad he's evil
you need to go out and like Drive
emotions talk of you know just create a
circumstance where you make them feel
something and then point them in the
direction of what what they that's what
the Democrats do they say bad stuff bad
stuff Donald Trump bad stuff our best
bet is like going out there talking
about the state of the economy right now
how American families are hurting talk
about this defund the police movement
and how it's hurting low-income minority
communities tug on the heartstrings
there and it's not a hard thing to do
because it's real it's actually
happening people are seeing it in their
backyard parents are getting galvanized
because their their students are being
affected in this public schooling system
that's completely failing them if you
use those emotional stories and then you
know plug in the facts there as you need
to uh people will get behind you I want
to pull up this tweet because uh we were
talking about
um you know like law and stuff came up
and I was thinking about this in the
context of where we're going Civil War
wise Marion Williamson was responding to
an Newsweek story about Trump getting
his special master that they're going to
review the document seized and she said
this is terrible news why is that
terrible Styx hexenhammer says how sad
that your Witch Hunt nonsense is being
put on hold for due process reasons she
responded does the law matter to you at
all or do you just think it doesn't
apply to him now here's the problem
Marion Williamson I actually I think
she's very nice sweet lady but this is
the issue with the left they don't care
about facts at all they care about how
they feel so they ignore facts they
don't do research and my response
the law stopped being relevant when
Democrats impeached Trump over Joe Biden
threatening the Ukrainian president with
illegally blocking U.S Aid guarantees or
maybe it was when they fabricated
evidence to spy on Trump the funny thing
is people like Mary Williamson don't
know that happened telling her doesn't
matter because it gives her a negative
emotional response you were wrong your
facts are bad and you're on the wrong
side negative emotional response don't
want to listen to you get away from me
right they only want sweet comforting
lies
well they want sweet comfort you know
they want life they prefer lies look
look whether whether they intentionally
say I want lies or a lie is what makes
them feel better and they request so
they're like make me feel better yeah I
love that line from viva Vendetta where
he says would you prefer a lie or the
truth
when when he gets asked by Evie about
you they want hope like kill that man
what was the so what is the situation
here what law what is being discussed
she says there's no due Pro there's
there's no rule of law so Donald Trump
they seize the documents Trump says a
special Master should review this to
make sure they're not going through
private stuff they're not allowed to
like good privileged documents and she
thinks you should not have to process
she's scared that the that the appointee
is going to be somewhat on his side that
they're going to help him out and she's
also scared of lengthening things out
before he announces whether or not he's
going to run for president so if they if
they have a hitter that they can use on
Trump before he puts in his candidacy
they want it now right and it's so sorry
let me let me squeeze this in real fast
it is so telling to me that they don't
want it to be possible for someone to
like Donald Trump's perspective no
insane he's already convicted in their
minds like for sure he committed a crime
we're just not totally sure what the
crime is is the logic there so why he
would need due processes sort of Beyond
can to them because he shouldn't he
should already be convicted they don't
want anything holding this up because
right he is already you know Persona
grata Enemy Number One there's no
recovering from that he doesn't deserve
the law that big mistake people are
making I think is that they're painting
a lot of social distress right now on
political parties like which is it the
Republicans causing this chaos or is it
the Democrats but in reality when you
look at videos in like Sri Lanka or in
Italy where people are rioting on the
street and smashing stuff and attacking
cops it's because they don't have heat
they don't have electricity that's what
that's going and going to cause civil
stress in this country it really doesn't
matter who's in political power at that
stage but everyone is going to say like
well you know you why you don't have the
things that you need to survive because
of that other party I uh Vladimir Putin
did this interview today where he was
like yeah Europe is sacrificing all of
their people uh to keep them American
globalist Elite in uh dominant power
like he is saying the exact same thing
we are all looking for someone else to
blame issues on but like with all of the
sanctions and energy bills are high you
can understand where that that line is
now going to potentially be persuasive
to at least Russians if not other people
who are like yeah our leadership is
really messing us up here how are we
going to get over what is it the system
they don't want I I I hate using the
term today it's so vague but Power
structures don't want people to be
empowered don't want people to have
unlimited electricity because then
they'll have more power than the
government and rise up and overthrow so
they've kept us in a state of
slaveocracy but that's going to cause
people to rise up it's like in one of
the greatest movie franchises of all
time Fast and Furious great
the villain in one of them I'm not sure
if it was five or not he said you know
you give the people something that
they're that they're scared to lose you
could take away and then you control
them then they're your slaves that was
my thought yeah so it's basically like
give them just enough you make their
lives better and then they're dependent
upon you it's like it's like it's like
you know it's not all bad in a sense
where you're making their lives a little
better but then you're also using it
specifically for control of
Tyrannosaurus Rex and hoping it doesn't
realize that it's a T-Rex and you're
just a little guy well it's like uh
there's a there's this famous meme where
there's a big elephant with like a rope
on its foot yeah exactly a little a
little spike in the ground and someone
said why won't the elephant just rip it
out and and walk away and I said when
the elephant was little it struggled and
fought and learned that it couldn't get
out now that it's older it doesn't even
bother trying and on top of that they're
they're also pushing this message of you
need to do this this is the this is for
the greater good like with this energy
stuff that's happening right now
entangled in that is the climate crisis
and hysteria surrounding that so not
only are you giving the government
control but you're doing it for a good
cause you're doing the right thing which
is exactly what's happening in the
Netherlands right now you know the
farmers are are up in arms about their
their livelihoods being taken away and
it is just a massive land grab from the
government but the government is saying
no it's for climate change this line
flattened the curve like covet taught us
you referenced the route it's really
Pavlov's a dog they ring the bell oh we
gotta flatten the curves and everyone
should fall in line and do this because
it's for the greater good that's right
so the rat hope experiment we've talked
about a bit before guy takes three rats
three cylinders puts the rats in the
cylinders they swim for 15 minutes can't
get out and then they just give up sink
and die then he takes another pair of
rats set of rats puts them in they swim
15 minutes or so they give up but this
time he lifts them out dries them off
lets them relax then puts them back in
the second time they swam for 60 hours
so we talked about this during the covid
lockdown are they going to rat
experiment us you put us in lockdown
everybody starts losing their minds and
they're right before it gets too bad you
stop you let every go back to normal you
bring the movies back you bring the
video games back the food's back the
pizza's back the wings are back and then
you give everybody a little bit to relax
dry off and then do it again and now
they'll last 60 60 times as long so if
you win let's put it this way 15 minutes
to 60 hours we're talking about what is
like a 200 was it 20 what are we doing
240 times 240 time increase so uh based
on the fact they locked us down for what
a year
are they now going to start pulling hard
back for another couple hundred years it
doesn't need to be that much it doesn't
need to translate you only need a
generation
because you lock down the the generation
of people that are used to living well
and have access to technology once they
accept their fate and say if we just
stay at it and flatten the curve then
eventually things will get better
people and the kids born into it will be
like this is well in slavery they never
have and they've always there's just a
history of Uprising against slavery
whether it's a monarchy or a corporation
or whatever like I I can't imagine that
people would sit still for very long
don't try for sure control is there is
there like a form of soft
totalitarianism where it's like you you
are somewhat enslaved but you have all
these wonderful amenities to keep you at
Bay and to keep you docile and you have
your streaming services and you have
just enough AC to keep your house cool
and you know just enough to be fine in
the place that you're at and without
enough energy to really realize how
oppressed you are yeah they have to
slowly take away from you because the
idea is you will own nothing and you
will be happy that's right and but but
this is true okay that's a true
statement you will owe nothing and you
will be happy is true you so we right
now are not unhappy that we don't have
access to flying cars and teleportation
I mean speak for yourself no I know some
people are like I wish I could teleport
but what I mean is
we mentioned this a little while ago
there was a video of a 90 year old man
in like the turn of the century 20 1900s
they recorded him he was alive in the
Civil War and they were like what's it
like with all this you know how was it
for you growing up with all the
technology now he's like the same people
get by they do the work they got to do
we got by just fine people get by now we
are we are accustomed to technology we
have we are not upset that we don't have
technology we don't know exists so if
they can take it away from you and then
remove it from your thoughts or the Next
Generation grows up without having it
they won't be unhappy because they won't
know it existed yeah I forget what
podcast I was watching this week but
they were talking about how it's
Humanity's greatest strength and our
greatest weakness that we can get used
to anything so there really hasn't been
a lot of humans thriving in slavery but
people do get used to it I don't know if
you remember and I'm sure Ian doesn't
know but in the Bible the Israelites
escaped slavery and they were so upset
in the desert they were like why can't
we go back to slavery that was better at
least we were fed right yeah this is a
thing that happens to humans and has
been happening since I mean look at
young people during this coveted
pandemic being locked down how quickly
they were like oh I'm totally fine being
home Also let's work from home now and
the way our Workforce has shifted is
subsequently it's we are very quickly
and you saw I used to see a lot of
content that was like somebody asked me
to get lunch before the pandemic and
you're like running errands you're doing
kind of stuff and then after the
pandemic like you have one social
interaction you're like I'm not for the
year I can't do too much like it
literally became something that people
are overwhelmed by when it was actually
a huge part of civilization working in
community and having regular contact
with other people like we are now more
isolated and the pandemic just made it
so we acclimated faster yeah but we're
more connected to the internet right
guys
betrayal of the powers the training
worked but I also think it's a big
marketing campaign it's a big psya so
you do remote work I'm actually not not
as opposed to remote work for a lot of
jobs some jobs require community and and
and you know cohesion but for a lot of
jobs like yeah you can work from home
for a lot of this stuff now you've got
people who are I don't want to go back
to work I want to work from home
yeah that's good for everything that's
going on at like reducing carbon
emissions all the climate change stuff
all the energy stuff they put people in
a position for a year then people get
accustomed to it and then beg for it
again that's what they like social
social manipulation social engineering
and this would be I don't want to put
too much weight on the world economic
Forum but I don't know who else they're
working with but the idea that people
are going into the pods that we're
creating like a race of Borg people pod
people that are people brains are hooked
to the to the machine and we're all kind
of seeing each other's thoughts and
working as one because the other the
other option is total chaos and
uprisings of people thinking they don't
have enough and fighting and killing and
destroying look I don't want everyone to
be black pilled here oh okay I want you
to see this story from Bloomberg oh good
yes yes thousands protest in Prague over
energy crisis demonstrators gathered a
protest against the government in Prague
I think in Italy they were burning their
energy bills is that Italy my UK doing
the same thing okay take a look at this
protests against the Indonesian
government's 30 percent gas price hiker
in full force watch as protesters try to
break down a wall of police officers and
riot gear this is apolitical yeah
is
people won't stand for this and I don't
believe Barack Obama or Bill Gates or
any of these people they are not
trustworthy people they come to me as a
young man and say good sir Urban liberal
we have a climate crisis at hand and I
say really tell me more and they say
that's right there's too many people
makes sense doesn't it deer get
overpopulated bird turkeys pigs they can
overpopulate right and I'm like yeah and
they go well we got a problem we can't
just kill people so we have to work
together to reduce our energy use reuse
and recycle and I'm like yeah that all
makes a lot of sense and they're like
now you get to it my private plane is
waiting to my beachfront property and
I'm like well hold on there a minute
hold on I sacrifice and then you bought
beachfront property in Martha's Vineyard
these people are full of it if they
really cared about this stuff they
wouldn't be doing the things they're
doing no but I think the reality is is
that they want to preserve what they
have they probably are worried about
overpopulation and political instability
but the reality is if we can get you to
sacrifice we get to keep our private
jets yeah so when they try to implement
these these these control mechanisms
it's like you mentioned Ian they want to
control the energy you get access to
because by limiting it it makes it
easier to control you if only the
wealthy Elites have access to the
internet or access to these you know you
know flying cars or whatever they're an
advantage over poor people and they can
more easily control them
so now what we see is people are
protesting and rising up saying we do
not agree with this and that's what we
need to see because if people just lay
down and accept this then you're all
going to be pod people basically sheep
or chickens internet's kind of helped us
to smash class systems like there used
to be the elites and the plebes or the
plebs at least and all through Society
there's been better men and everybody
else you know whatever in the Americas
they were the better men that made the
government but I think people are are
not everybody but more willing to
represent themselves
what Tim is saying is reminding me of
the criticism of the North America free
trade agreement it was like here's what
we're going to do as a collective you a
U.S Canada Mexico and part of the
environmental policies we're like we're
going to reduce carbon and do whatever
and Mexico never reduced their uh carbon
emissions and so it was like wait we
were we said we were all in this
together and it was like why are we why
are we staying in this agreement in this
partnership that's not working I feel
like that's the same thing that these
people are saying like we rely on you to
protect us and you are swearing
allegiance to A system that is causing
us to suffer like you are supposed to
put our interests first right they're
realizing their public servants are not
serving them anymore and that there is a
clear I think the class divide is to be
getting just so abundantly clear
especially through the internet and
independent journalism like if we
weren't talking about this and these
independent journalists weren't talking
about this nobody would know that all
these separate protests are happening
right now but now we're getting videos
coming out and in different people are
jumping on the movements in the
Netherlands when that started sooner or
later France jumps in Spain jumps in
because they all know this is going to
be a collective fight I mean it was the
same thing with the freedom Convoy right
we saw it happening in Canada and people
were like oh wait yeah I don't want this
either we're gonna we're gonna act and
you didn't see it modeled as heavily
anywhere outside Canada I mean people
carried out to a certain extent but like
that reminded everyone that like you
don't have to lay down and conform to
what's going on especially if it's
harming you I think it's funny I
remember the Arab Spring
you had uh uh people using Facebook and
Twitter to organize Mass protests in
these Arabic Nations and then you know
overthrow their governments Egypt it
twice
and then uh we started seeing that with
Occupy Wall Street people start
organizing and protesting occupy I think
got co-opted by you know
special interests but the ability to use
social media to organize and reject the
centralized Control Systems is extremely
apparent and now they're desperately
trying to put a stop to it they have to
ban people like Alex Jones they have to
silence as many as many of these voices
as possible and they they first started
going through going for big names Alex
Jones for instance Miley nopalist Laura
Loomer none they started going after the
smaller accounts because they were like
hey maybe we can do it that way go after
a million small accounts that aren't big
enough to make a splash if they get
banned as opposed to the big one that
makes a big news cycle if you do ban so
that's the strategy now another thing
obviously is Shadow Banning and you know
algorithmic manipulation the second
benefit that I heard to them is you know
you ban these people and if you're
saying like oh these they hold extreme
views and they get purged they look for
an alternative right so Andrew talked
about like gab was not a inherently
political uh alternative to Twitter
except that they banned all of the
extreme right-wing users first so they
were like well we'll go to gab and so
that gave the platform on natural
leaning even though it wasn't how he
started it then you can have anyone at
Twitter be like well what are you going
to do join that crazy extremist platform
it siphoned off society and made it so
you can point directly where you should
not go next the internet is very
powerful I mean like look at China and
what's happening there right now there's
protests erupting all over China because
people can't get their money out of the
banks but there's no they have such a
stronghold on social media and the
information that you're allowed to get
out of to people that it's so hard to
State approach yes it may feel it's
going to be like who is getting banned
first because whatever they're doing
maybe I don't agree with it but I want
to know because if they're getting
purged first just just be aware of it
like why are they getting purged well
they do a lot of things somebody
commented already that um you know we've
got 40 000 people listening to the show
right now concurrent viewership we're
not trending on YouTube when you search
for it you can't find it
and it's election season so we knew this
was going to happen yeah but uh
unsurprising has that always been that
way with the show like did you ever
trend on YouTube I can't remember I I
think yes early on we we did Trend
several times I'm pretty sure and then
all of a sudden one day I remember Tim
cast IRL you couldn't search for it on
Google anymore you would take the title
verbat and put it in Google and Facebook
would come up instead and it was just
funny and then it was after like a year
or so all of a sudden
I mentioned it on the show the next day
we reappeared in search but they I think
it was more that they realized it was so
overt people were catching on to their
suppression right now I think it's funny
because um we put out a song last week
everybody knows at this point I guess
and it was trending number 23 on YouTube
which is funny because this show gets
more views and it never Trends but this
is the point of the culture War putting
out music is apolitical boy are they
really salty that we did that and
succeeded at it they're freaking out
some are but it was a good song so they
get that well it's like overwhelming
thumbs up and positive but the corporate
press is losing their minds when it
comes to admitting social networks
politics is kind of a risky admin
because if you decide to let politics
run on the front page of your Social
Network you're basically taking a
political stance as a as a social
network administrator whether you want
to or not so you I used to put that
stuff in its own bucket like if you want
politics you got to go look for it I'm
not gonna push it at you I'm pushing you
know letting entertainment or what and
it's like that's a dirty surface level
way to go but politics is really dirty
too and I don't I don't think that just
because someone's got the loudest voice
necessarily means that everyone should
be looking at it people want Power well
here's question are are left-leaning
people ever trending on YouTube do you
guys keep up with that stuff yeah you
see yes well I don't I don't know about
prominent uh overtly political yeah I
don't know about that if you look at it
it's usually music and like Mr Beast no
so every single time I turn on my Smart
TV it's on YouTube and it's on The Young
Turks every time well it doesn't matter
what I do The Young Turks are an
approved YouTube TV station right like
they're they're you get YouTube TV and
they're a channel why aren't we a
channel yeah what the heck it's a good
idea well they they have 24-hour
coverage I'm pretty sure like they have
something running on reruns on like a
live stream for a chance
so we could have a whole show where I
just Vamp for an hour
well I mean we're getting we're getting
we're getting there we have we have pop
culture crisis three to five we have Tim
cast IRL eight to ten we gotta start
filling these these time slots with
other shows we're going to be launching
the conspiracy show with Shane Cashman
which is like a call-in show it's not
going to be live though but we could air
it in a time slot and then maybe
eventually get a 24-hour rolling live
stream does Young Turks do a website
where you pay 10 bucks a month and get
their stuff yep oh okay
I think we have more I think we're
bigger than they are to be honest I'm
not sure I see a lot of left-leaning not
always like a politician or a commenter
but I do see a lot of presentation of
you know it seems like fun internet
content right like rank all these people
like best fashion but it's always you
know you have to look at the people they
have certain ideologies they'll talk
about how they don't like certain things
and it's never from the conservatives
perspective it's always and I think
that's partially because YouTube has
flagged let's say left-leaning culture
as mainstream culture yeah it's moving
us towards a left-leaning spectrum when
we know that's not actually accurate for
most of America exactly that is why I
started been making videos I was just
sort of a passive user of social media
but then I started realizing how they
curate the content based on your
demographics and what they know about
you and I started getting all this stuff
about black lives matter and the black
struggle and the feminist struggle and I
thought is there nobody to counteract
this on social media and of course they
are but they're just getting throttled
left and right yeah yeah it's
unbelievable yeah oh man I'm Gonna Save
something for uh the next 17-20 minutes
to give a quick update on on the on the
culture War issues so I'll save it but
uh yeah the issue with the uh with
Facebook and Twitter is algorithmic and
early on what happened was people who
ran these big tech companies were
naturally left leaning they think
they're the majority so they would ban
what they thought was not normal it's
it's literally exemplified in that Meme
where it's like the left and the right
and Bernie Sanders is placed in the
middle and there's nothing on the left
and it's like watch this space and
they're like it's like it's like dude
Bernie Sanders literally wants uh the
people to own percentages of
Corporations that's socialist like
overtly if you think he's a Centrist
you're an occult but they do they think
I'm I'm a middle of the road person and
and Bernie Sanders is in the middle of
the road no no he's not Yeah by no
metric not by left and right uh
Progressive like cultural standards and
not by economic standards he's left he's
fairly far left actually yeah but they
think they're in the middle so they ban
you well it's the tech you're totally
right it's Tech Executives as well as
the area that they're in right so if we
think of Hollywood and Silicon Valley as
similar areas both those Industries are
dominated people who think who are
already naturally left-leaning and then
they walk outside and their kids have
friends at school who aren't in the
industry and they're also left leaning
and then it gets reinforced over and
over again it's why I'm so interested in
businesses like uh daily wire setting up
in in Tennessee like businesses that
want to produce content especially now
that the internet gives us that
flexibility who settle in places that
are not decentralized you know Echo
Chambers they're physical Echo Chambers
where people all sort of think the same
thing I would like to bring you to the
world of Alexandria ocasio-cortez in
this tweet from Ursula perano she says
AOC on talks about her future Ambitions
with a heavy comment quote realistically
I can't even tell you if I'm going to be
alive in September and that weighs very
heavily on me all right hold on hold on
girl did some mushrooms
now hold on there's several questions
does she have a terminal disease right I
hope not okay it's called life yes is
she suicide that's a serious question
because saying something like that I
think people haven't thought about what
she could do by this suicidal right and
if she's not sick and she says something
like I don't know if I'll be alive
usually that's a sign of depression
especially in the context of this
article she says a woman of color can
never be present because people hate
them or something it's like very
negative she was crying when she said
this really she they said that she had
tears in her eyes yeah but but you know
what we saw the fence maybe she needs
like a 5150 or something she needs to be
brought somewhere and given an
evaluation because if you tell people
crying that you don't know if you're
going to be alive in September we need
to sit you down and ask you what's wrong
because if you ignore this something bad
could happen we want her to be okay and
I know the left is going to be like oh
shut up they're like no dude you okay
we're gonna play a game pick one do you
think she's referring to a Civil War and
that racists would come and kill her by
September yes you think that's what
she's talking about I think she's shook
up you think January 6th thing and it
hasn't left you think that a couple
weeks ago she was sitting there thinking
okay couple weeks from now a bunch of
white racists are gonna start a Civil
War and I'm gonna die she probably
thinks that she's a Target if something
like that were to happen after January
6th she was like I I could have died
yeah but she's not walking around
see this is this is my point right the
Assumption a lot of people make is that
she must be talking about like what
Kathy Griffin is talking about something
like that the other question is okay all
right most people are probably going to
think it's something to do with
political conflict we still have to ask
questions about like dude I'm the Civil
War guy I'm like ranting and raving
about it and I don't think in three
weeks there's gonna be a bunch of
racists go around hunting down women
climate change
her comments were more of like uh Mark
Ruffalo didn't he have this thing he's
like if we're around yeah she did say
the world was going to end in 12 years a
few years ago
it wouldn't matter if she's alive or
dead like when you're living your
purpose you don't lament about when it
might end you're just doing it so
obviously maybe she's lost a lack of
purpose she feels kind of aimless this
was a a crazy interview on a lot of
friends I also enjoyed during it that
she said she wasn't sure it would be
like good for her to marry a white guy
she's currently engaged to a white guy
and she's been dating she's like she's
gonna kill me in my sleep she's got a
lot of anxiety she needs to work out and
I'm I'm being a little sarcastic there
but also like you are setting yourself
up for a lot of scenarios where you feel
like at any point your life could fall
apart and or be in danger like something
is wrong I think she might be suicidal
really maybe I think I think we we are
looking through the lens of the culture
War
and so we're assuming that someone
political like AOC must be referring to
what we see instead of asking a very
simple question when you hear Hooves
it's not zebras it's usually horses the
GQ article says tears pooled in the
corners of her eyes she says I hold two
contractory things in my mind one is the
Relentless belief that doesn't mean
anything is possible at the same time my
experience here has given me a front row
seat how deeply and unconsciously as
well as consciously so many of those
people in this country hate women and
they hate women of color people ask me
questions about the future and
realistically I can't even tell if I'm
going to be alive in September why is
the immediate assumption like if if you
if you started off from a blanket no
reference to any individual and said
someone says that in three weeks they
might not be alive your immediate
reaction well they're talking about
Civil War no yeah you'd say wellness
check yeah you'd be like okay why do you
think that the first question might be
like are they sick like someone who
thinks they're gonna die in a few weeks
are they terminally ill they have cancer
I mean maybe AOC does and we don't know
about it I don't know but I think I I
either look either she's insane and she
thinks that a bunch of crazy extremists
are going to come kill her which
that sounds insane or she's depressed
and crying in an interview about how
people hate women of color and she
doesn't know she'll be alive in
September right but yeah her leading
with the people hate women of color is
the thing that's kind of bringing me
into the fact that maybe she's talking
about extremism or but also if you grew
up always believing that you are the
victim and your job is to overcome
you've got to do it and like you're also
the victim but you're still kind of
winning because you got to Congress but
also you're still the victim either way
exactly what is that like I hold two
contradictory things on my mind like
this is a very popular divided person if
if she said this to like a
psychotherapist who wasn't involved in
the political world he'd probably be
like
um
three-month vacation girl well well
three days an evaluation Hawaii or
something and look at the waves yeah if
she genuinely believes that there's
going to be white racist men hunting
women of color that and that's why
she'll die she needs serious therapy she
needs a break right now I don't know how
long but she needs to get out and she
needs to go talk to a doctor because
that's crazy she's I think it's I think
it's a fair assessment to say she lives
in a world where Biden comes out and
says the Maga extremists are a threat to
this country where she hears in the news
all day about white supremacists and she
genuinely internalizes and believes this
is the world she lives in that's
possible too but I also think that is
still using our echo echo chamber world
view we know about political problems so
to a hammer everything looks like a nail
we assume that political people must
view the world this way and if she does
that's the real reason when in reality
it's like dude she's extremely high
profile she gets people [ __ ] on her
all the time maybe she's just like
a lot I can have a lot of empathy for
that uh you know I will point out again
I know it sounds random but she did get
engaged in April and I think that the
idea that she's moving forward with this
high profile relationship she's already
in Congress like where do I go from this
Pinnacle career I mean people regularly
include her in polls to become president
like what if she is actually unhappy
with where her life is she can't walk
away from this right it was a big big
change like people rag on her I think it
was great that she was a bartender I
think that the idea that a regular
person can you know get a seat in
Congress is fantastic I think it's
stupid to insult her over it but imagine
going from no public Persona to being
the one of the highest profile Democrats
yo it is stressful one of the highest
ranking officers on the Death Star the
United States the military machine is
the Death Star and all these people
working in Congress are serving on the
Death Star so I understand her State of
Mind is broken because she's like what
am I doing what like that's just
existential that's like underneath the
the content on top of what she's been
feeling and this girl's tuned in
emotionally she's like we're talking
about leftists are emotional rightists
are logical but she's very emotionally
enlightened with what she's feeling like
with Mark Ruffalo he was asked will you
be the The Hulk in the future and he
goes if the world allows it and I'm
still around the interviewer didn't
follow up with hold on there a minute do
you think you're gonna die the interview
are here as well like well you're not
going to be alive in September a good
interview is going to be like are you
sick yeah are you depressed or do you
think the war is going to break out in a
couple weeks especially if she's been on
the verge of tears throughout this whole
interview well I don't know about the
whole interview it said that's that
point right if you're hitting emotional
notes in an interview and then this
other person said I'm like and I'm gonna
I might not even be alive in September
like you're not having a like haha we're
joking around I don't even know if I'll
be alive then like you have to respond
to the gravitas of what's going on this
seems like I got a clarifying question
only hitting with serious notes
appealing breaking moment right now
maybe I went through that in 2008 and I
was suicidal I thought for sure like I
gave up I thought oh the world like
we've got the Federal Reserve as we've
been under this system like there's no
ho I had completely given up but I I
still wanted to have hope I had that
other part of my brain like she's saying
where I'm like I know everything's
possible here's what I want you all to
do right now and just stop a second
imagine someone sitting in front of you
think of a random person you know crying
says to you I might not be alive in a
few weeks well why why that was the
first thing I would say but exactly the
fact that she said this it's like again
we're approaching this from a political
perspective yeah think about how you
would feel if someone you knew told you
that yeah so I'd be like yo you we need
a doctor like yeah okay for the next
three weeks I'm the doctor right now I'm
not a doctor by the way but tell me why
at least you know let's start with
friendship and then if it's unresolvable
maybe we'll get a Psychotherapy yeah
this is this is a crazy thing to say and
they probably a crazy thing to not
follow up on especially like where's the
journalist in this one Wesley Lowry what
are you doing okay so journalists aren't
mandatory reporters like you have in the
hospital in the hospital if somebody
said something like this yes you are on
suicide watch you don't get to have any
chords you don't have any Cutlery you
have to eat finger foods let's clarify
that if if in the hospital someone told
you I might not be alive in a few weeks
you would report them and we would put
them on suicide watch which was
supposedly what Epstein was on he
clearly wasn't because he still had
access to Sheets you don't have access
to anything right when you get arrested
they take your shoelaces and your belt
away exactly and and because they don't
want you to kill yourself or someone
else I would imagine yeah several family
members Baker acted and as soon as you
say anything toward the lines of of
harming yourself it's immediate you're
being put in a facility and you're there
until they feel like you're not a threat
to yourself but you know you know what's
going to happen she's making this
comment to a journalist like what is she
saying to people she really trusts and
knows like that's what's disturbing to
me I think what you're going to hear is
many on the left are going to dismiss
this downplay it say it's the far right
because they would prefer she be in a
desperate and dangerous position if it
wins their wins for them politically
that's right they don't care about her
also the sad part if she did go and do
something to herself the amount of
people who would like use it as a story
and use it as a way to move forward
their political agenda another
possibility is she is a sociopathic
narcissist who faked tears and said this
to try and win brownie points in the
media not think like believing to
herself there's no real threat and she's
just a crazy person well and if she's
someone whose emotional spectrum is kind
of off she can perform motion she knows
how to cry you know on Q let's say but
she doesn't actually always feel the
weight of her words you know she can say
like I'm not not even be alive and not
know what what the appropriate response
got to be like if she pictured someone's
in front of her saying I might not be
alive in September would she respond
with like we need to talk about that are
you okay or would you respond with like
well I really need you to vote I know
early then I know what's going on what's
going on tell us AOC
is likely depressed because of Instagram
and Tick Tock I actually believe that
she's not getting enough likes yeah we
have this story from the Daily Mail
addicted to being sad teenage girls with
invisible illnesses known as spoonies
post tick tocks of themselves crying or
in hospital to generate thousands of
likes as experts raise concerns over
internet-induced wave of mass anxiety
this is real it's true that young women
are getting depressed because of
Instagram and Tick Tock and as as far as
it goes with AOC we were just talking
about how she said she might not be
alive in September which to me is
indication an indication of depression
or severe I don't know what would you
call it like paranoia but I also think
it's possible that
you know she's in the Limelight
in this position if she starts putting
out posts like any other individual
susceptible to depression from these
platforms and she's not getting the
likes or the attention she might get
depressed and we're seeing this now with
teenage girls across the board well and
she is one of the most followed like has
the biggest social media presence of any
member of Congress I mean she has really
cultivated her brand as being someone
who is in touch with her followers she
does upgrades updates through her
Instagram live and through Twitter and
things like that like as well as shares
her skincare routine and she sells fun
merch like she is as much an influencer
as she is a politician and public figure
in so many ways she's more an influencer
right yeah exactly and so in some ways
you know I could see if she's won
re-election and she's had this moment
where she was sort of this fun Golden
Girl for the left uh and if any of those
numbers Drop Like if she's getting 80
000 likes on a photo instead of the 110
000 she's gonna feel that burn so
intensely the same way that you know
teenage girls are susceptible to it too
but like it is not just her identity
it's also her career you see this
throughout the history of YouTube
one day a popular YouTuber will make a
video saying like I can't do this
anymore and then all you got to do is
look at the views for their past videos
and you see them going down and then all
of a sudden they snap yep so people it's
really amazing to me I remember getting
a message from someone it happens all
the time and they're like are your views
down and then I'll be like yes and
they'll be like dude something's going
on I'm like it's called Summer yeah
it's happened people went outside calm
down like you see I see these Trends all
the time and there are people who you
know there was promote global warming so
they stay inside well I remember uh you
know like two years ago it rained for a
week straight on the East Coast across
the board and then one day I got message
of people being like dude My Views are
cut in half I'm panicking look what's
going on I'm like bro the rain stopped
everybody went outside for the first
time in a week calm down man but this is
what happens to these young girls on on
social media they'll post a picture of
themselves get 100 likes and go oh 100.
the next thing they get 80. they get
depressed they Panic why aren't they
getting likes they delete the photo and
repost one can I do better can I do
better not realizing bro it's like two
in the morning people are asleep calm
down I knew girls who would when they
traveled out of the country they would
time their Instagram posts to go up
they'd like set alarm for like 3 A.M so
it was the correct time to post in
America to get the maximum likes like I
didn't even grow up with Tick Tock like
this is crazy right and I think social
media is really morphed too where not
only are we seeking validation through
the likes but your depression and
anxiety is affirmed through social media
like social media used to be a highlight
reel for people's lives you follow these
influencers but you know it's not real
like they're in Hawaii but they're
probably arguing with their boyfriends
behind the scenes whatever the case may
be now it's a trend to cry on social
media it's a trend to show your panic
attacks and that gets you millions of
likes or having like anxiety coping like
here are my anxiety copes or here's my
OCD copes or who are these things that I
think I'm doing that are actually very
Strange Behaviors or misspelling words
so that'll do it too yeah so um it's
true that if you misspell a word in your
title you'll get more engagement as
people want to correct you wow so what
happened is a bunch of YouTubers started
intentionally misspelling words like
simple typos and then little kids who
are watching it started misspelling the
words that way thinking it was spelled
correctly yeah social media is is
melting the brains of humanity yes and
particularly young girls I did an
episode one time because I was scrolling
on on Tick Tock I do have the app
regrettably but I was scrolling part of
your job it is part of my job but I kept
getting videos of young girls who have
Tourette's like ticks and I kept getting
them and it's multiple girls multiple
girls and I was getting recommended
these videos and upon watching them
found that several of them had the exact
same tick so I started looking into this
and doctors talking about it and they
actually had doctors saying these girls
are being so heavily influenced by a mix
of anxiety and Tick Tock they are they
are developing functional neurological
disorders that are real
that are real they're not just puppeting
and parroting they're actually
developing these anxiety-induced I'm a
huge fan of video games but man we are
tweaking our brains with modern
technology it's like a big experiment
dude the emotional development that
teenagers going through like part of
being a teenager is looking at your
peers around you and figuring out what
the social norms are so if you're only
being fed people who are behaving in you
know maybe they really do have
Tourette's and they have you know an
issue and they're trying to talk about
it or bring awareness but if you're
constantly being served like I have
anxiety I have depression I have
Tourette's like you are then trained to
be like maybe I do too and you start
seeing it anywhere because that's part
of the emotional growth that teenagers
are going through like yeah we should
keep them away from this stuff it's it's
all we shouldn't talk about mental
health or anything like that but like we
don't need to shove it down their
throats so constantly that they become
paranoid they themselves one of the
things is that I've noticed is it's not
so important how many followers you have
it's the quality of the followers are
they really why are they following you
is it because they're really listening
to what you're saying or is it because
they want to laugh when you fall down I
don't those people following me and the
problem with social media is just the
number shows on your page so they think
more is better but then you get the
Subscribe direct subscribers this is
where you start to realize the quality
of the follower uh or The Watcher or the
viewer or whatever is much better
because you might have 10 000 people
paying you 10 bucks a month that he
might have 10 million people watching
paying him nothing he's way worse off
you're way better off with less
followers more quality and um hopefully
young women we can teach them that maybe
through direct support subscriptions and
they see the internet as the Beyond
end-all there's I don't remember what
study came out but most young people
like One of four want to be social media
influencers this is a whole new area of
the world that they are completely
devoted to right and they will never
have a break from it if that's the
career they choose to pursue yeah it's
an augmentation to your career social
media no one is just gonna land on being
a social media influencer and that's it
because if your life is boring no one's
going to watch your social media you've
got to do something cool with your life
and then the social media will be there
to show everyone what you have to sell
all of your personal information you
have to as a young teen mom start
talking about your past relationships or
you know as you get married you have to
give all the details of everything
that's going on you have to sell who you
are in order to please people which is a
really morally Corruption of living yeah
I remember when I was younger in the you
know like Myspace first came out and
stuff like that we were on I think it
was like live Journal was first America
yeah I was on CompuServe you know
because my family computers then you got
AOL yeah then with AOL yeah you're at
geocities and other sites that you can
you can make your own site then
eventually you got like live Journal
then you got Friendster you guys
remember hell yeah and then Myspace oh
yeah and I remember uh Facebook came out
and it was like all the cool kids that
are migrating to Facebook and I would
see these posts from people that just
looked so awesome and fun and I was like
how come they're doing all this really
awesome stuff and I'm not and then you
know it wasn't until later I realized
like oh they weren't they were faking
cool things so they could look cool and
like that was theirs it was marketing
and so we end up we end up seeing this
highlight reel of their life of all the
coolest things they've done but they
staged a lot of it they try to make it
look as cool as possible they try to
make their lives look like movies so
that you're jealous of them yep my
favorite is I know girls who have um
when they go through a breakup right
they start posting on their Instagram
and all their story all the time because
they can't be the one that's at home and
like sad they'd have to be busy and cool
and having a great time and their mind
is somewhere else like these people
don't realize they're robbing themselves
of their own actual individual lives for
the sake of other people who are viewing
from their bedrooms yes all they're
giving away is their own time which ends
up being their lives and I do want to
say before we move on from the AI all
this AOC talk she's talking about
holding two completely different views
in her mind at the same time I think
she's about to get red pill change my
mind that's what it feels like I hope
I'm right I kind of went through
something similar where I well I already
mentioned this earlier yeah sorry oh I
truly believed in the possibility of of
the human race but at the same time
seeing this insurmountable you know
mountain of impossibility that I was up
against and like how the hell can I
overcome a global monetary assistant
well but what if also a lot of things
that she's been preaching are not
working and she's having to reconcile
the fact that like there are policies
that she is vocally back that she
doesn't actually she's not sure she
supports she isn't just a person she is
a brand an identity that a lot of lefts
want to cultivate in their own daughters
like she can't we talk about this with
jazz Jennings sometimes like there's
nowhere to go from there like this
person can only continue down this path
and that's scary AOC can't come out and
be like well that one bipartisan bill
seems kind of good you know she can't
she has to continue down this path to
get voted back in right and like if she
you she's going to get married right
what if she gets pregnant she's like
well actually I'm going to leave
politics because I want to be a mom
that's anti-feminist like oh you know I
have some questions about the way
lockdown went you know maybe that's not
so good she's anti-coveted you know
there is no Escape for her and in some
ways I have sympathy yeah that's true
you can't say I was wrong the most
feminist thing you can do Alex is
whatever you want
take control of your life baby
at the table you have to have a baby
that's why I said yeah yeah have a
family and do whatever you want you can
always do politics later yeah there you
go yes well I mean if she's doing
yeah but I think like right now the
whole trend is not to have a family and
it's like you have to actually resist
the current to have a family which is
the funniest thing you know it's like
it's been a meme forever to have it all
so the women who are like you know I
decided I don't want to have a job and a
career I want to raise children it's
like it's against the grain but it is
massively feminist to do that to take
control of your life if you want a baby
well that's why I think they intercede I
don't know I mean how many people you
know who are feeling the pressure to
decide in your early 20s that you
actually don't want kids and make a
permanent decision right to go past that
like they are trying to head the South
pass because a lot of times you actually
hear it from women who are in their late
20s or in their early 30s were like I
thought the crew was the most important
thing but I've reached this age and I
actually would prefer to focus on my
family and if you can prevent people
from Ever having that door when they hit
30 they have to continue to stand by
that they made the right choice to get a
hysterectomy when they were 21. Wicked
cycle Wicked cycle and then if you
decide at 30 that you want a family but
you don't have the man yet and you don't
have the you know song Your Song also
yeah up I tweeted this
abortions increase the likelihood of
miscarriage
so entirely Target yeah it's it's it's a
very basic thing I you know I saw the
story from Jennifer Lawrence and she was
like Roe v Wade and things like that and
then I was like
look if you support this stuff like
women need to be told this that if you
get abortions so like I look use condoms
or whatever try not to get pregnant but
if you get an abortion you are
increasing likely that when you're older
you're not gonna be able to have kids
and that's because there's there's
damage that's caused by it it's the same
thing with taking birth control for
years like those have long-term effects
on the bodies but because it's seen as
this revolutionary tool that helped many
women join the workforce and gain
control of their body like we're not
supposed to criticize it and I actually
think that sets us behind I've known a
lot of women who have struggled with you
know anxiety depression different things
like that and really had to push their
doctors to be honest about the
consequences of taking hormonal birth
control and that's scary that's insane
you can't even get accurate information
because it goes against an ideology that
we are supposed to be 100 behind yeah
we've just jumped into a culture that
says this is accepted here's the thing
you need to do now do it and then 20
years later when we have the
ramifications of it we're gonna be like
and I I wish women would hear that like
you are they are willing to sacrifice
you and your personal choice in Freedom
and health to maintain this illusion
that the ideology they pushed is worth
having around dude if you are willing to
give up your power to Medical tyrannists
they will take it but it's empowering
Ian if you take the birth control pill
it's empowering I this is terrifying
what you just said Amala because I think
that this is exactly what's happening
with the kids now so you know how like
however many years ago it was birth
control was an un you know unknown but
they still encouraged people to take it
it was so easy for me to get on birth
control I had to I like half made up an
excuse because like I'm 19 now it's time
I gotta figure this out right be smart
or whatever and it was easy it was the
easiest thing in the world and I'm
terrified they're gonna do the same
thing with human hormones before we go
to super chats I want to give everybody
an update on the the song because it is
now officially the end of the reporting
period ended in Thursday and uh there's
a bunch of really good news and um a
bunch of really fun news for those that
are interested so the first thing I want
to say is only ever wanted the song we
released uh the 26th of August is the
number two most sold song in the U.S for
the week of September 10th we could not
beat Elton John and Britney Spears but
number two cool with your help so we
were the second most sold song in the
country that's massive that's huge and
the first song we officially released
hit the charts number 21 on rock and
number 24 on hot rock and alternative
and uh there's actually a bunch of
others this is really funny
so we're number one alternative digital
sales number 24 hot rocket alternative
number 21 Rock number 28 in Canadian
sales nice number one in rock sales
number 21 uh on rock and will of the
people which were released two years ago
hit number 17 in alternative digital
sales which is huge and I'll tell you
exactly why this mattered and I was
correct
um and and you were as well I knew that
invading the cultural spaces with
apolitical content was going to trigger
them to an extreme degree and not only
did they put produce a bunch of videos
ragging on the song completely getting
disproven they're saying oh the song is
bad and it's stupid and we hate it and
uh it's got like 70 000 likes 1.7
million it's got tons of streams number
two digital song sales you can't lie
with the Billboard charts we objectively
placed among some of the biggest songs
in the country there are a bunch of
bands that I'm a huge fan of that
release songs all the time that never
chart and I'm sure you know that exactly
is the same thing but here's the best
part
um without getting into specifics when
our Communications people started
reaching out and saying here's a song
from Pete Parada Tim Paul and Carter
Banks they got so effing pissed no joke
industry press we're gonna for the time
being
until I can do a deeper assessment not
going to reveal the names of these
individuals and the things they said but
they were legit
effing pissed I hate these people a few
like kind of stuff refusing to write
about it I love it it's like does your
biased against someone preclude you from
doing your job apparently well here's
the best part they cannot ignore it
there are tons of mainstream established
rock bands that don't chart when they
release songs and uh oh we did so how
long are they going to be able to hold
out ignoring the fact that we put out
music that lands on all of their charts
it's going to get really funny when
after the third time we chart they're
like we're still not gonna write about
this and then people start saying like
hey wait a minute man that song on the
radio you're not writing about
something's messed up Fifth hit that
comes out will be they'll they'll all of
a sudden they'll write about and be like
well we always loved Tim pool we always
loved good rock band or whatever the
hell it's called good yeah that's what's
gonna happen I hope that's the case the
retconning so uh there are some issues
with reporting on some of the numbers
just take a look at what happened with
Tom McDonald when he talked about how
his numbers weren't tracked properly and
they wouldn't put them on Billboard and
things like that we've we've we've
bumped into a little bit of that but
they can't deny it because sometimes the
numbers are too much based on the
metrics we got and where we landed in
the charts I am 100 confident that the
next song we put out is going to chart
substantially higher and they're not
going to be able to ignore the fact that
we are pushing into the cultural spaces
they once owned and don't own anymore it
might be the third hit when they start
writing about it I've said fifth it
might be the third maybe I just that
this is the point and so let me just say
the behind the scenes I'm talking with a
bunch of other big companies and artists
who have seen similar problems and are
sick and tired of the woke cult
controlling The Establishment
controlling the Arts and so we're
talking and uh some fun and funny stuff
is going to happen and then I'm uh look
number two on Billboard for sales and
now what are they saying sales don't
matter sales are they don't matter oh
okay yeah tell it to Nicki Minaj tell
that to DJ Khaled they're on the look we
beat DJ Khaled God dead now I get it not
everybody buys these days but it's still
one of Billboard's top charts sales it
matters and regardless of that I'm not
saying we came out with the Hot 100
number one hit I didn't expect we would
get anywhere to be honest a bunch of my
favorite bands don't even make the
charts and we did they're really pissed
off about it and we're going to keep
pissing them off so thank you all so
much for helping us do that and uh we're
gonna keep putting up music and we're
going to build that Library we're gonna
be signing other artists and we're going
to go for people like look
the daily wire brought on Gina Corrado
when they canceled her and boy did the
corporate institutions they got all
pissed off she was canceled she wasn't
supposed to be working and doing movies
now she's in a bunch of movies she's
doing better than ever they're trying to
keep you in fear so that when you work
for them you don't speak out and you
don't speak up because then you'll lose
your job when we succeed at producing
this and we plan on moving forward
signing more bands and producing more
music how long until another industry
executive or an engineer or producer
says you know what I don't need to work
for this garbage anymore because I can
go work for any of these other companies
that's what we need to build and that
comes from the success of the projects
we're working on do I think it's the
greatest song ever written I don't know
it's just a song we wrote and produced
but apparently it did well enough the
next one put out is going to be even
better so thank you again everybody for
for your support and um we'll see what
happens with you know my attitude is I
want to publish all the emails from
these people so you can see just how how
angry they are but maybe it's not a good
idea you know I got I got to see they're
not my emails we use a we use a third
party company so not my emails to share
but what I'm hearing is there's like
effectively saying F off and Fu and
they're they're very very angry about it
it's kind of like an inoculation someone
gets a shot in the arm they're like ow
that hurt but if if you like show
everyone what a you know what a what a
pansy they were when they got the shot
they're not gonna like you in the future
but after the inoculation they feel
better they're like ah okay it was you
know we're gonna keep making videos a
little sooner or later one of the songs
we make will chart very very high and
maybe B maybe be a top 40 or something
and it's going to be really funny when
they finally begrudgingly with anger in
their eyes right
song by Tim Cassidy good and people
really like it for making me laugh again
maybe it won't be a song by me it'll be
a song by someone we sign but the fact
is when we put out this music and I'm
gonna tell you guys how it works right
now
let you run on some industry secrets
so uh
and I think the CPM for songs is like
five bucks what is it like five dollars
for every thousand or something like
that I could be wrong but uh when you're
a band and you put out 20 years of music
and you've got a hundred songs you're
not charting it's the volume that people
across the board listen to music that
makes you money so we're looking at from
a business perspective we're gonna be
able to produce music and make money
that's the goal now that it's looking
like we're gonna be able to make money
doing this we can sign a bunch of bands
and build up a label and then uh we're
gonna take over the cultural
institutions thank you very much let's
we'll start reading some super chat so
smash the like button you're not even
saying that in front of a Podium with
red light behind you they're not as
scary as with anyone yeah but still
moving you should have dim the lights
while he was talking yes all right
YouTube's giving me the business but
we're gonna pull up some uh super chats
if we can because the thing keeps
crashing so smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends all that good stuff
here we go Super Chat time
all right
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim I blame
you I'm stressed before you I was
ignorant to the evil set out to destroy
us now I daily rack my brain how can I
help what more can I do though in the
end I effing love America Ty for new
eyes no look like people are screaming
at CNN is moving to the right or
whatever they're calling for boycotts
yeah we're winning they're thrashing
about it may get bad but the reality is
we're winning the culture War as
everything I described with the music
stuff yeah they're really mad about that
I love it do you think it's fair to say
that in some ways they are moving to the
right because they were so far left and
now was it Chris Lish is his name he was
like I don't want as much partisan we
have to get back to being sender and so
the criticism that they're moving to the
right in some ways is true although like
not the way they're presenting it I'm
moving to the center right to get right
back to the center like it doesn't make
any sense I think we're winning I don't
know I feel like we are too like how
much more can this be sustained the
complacency alarm goes off
you still have to be active Victory is
when these corporations say we can't do
this anti-trump stuff it's hurting the
business and CNN starts laying people
off for ideologically driven and not
fact-driven then yes we are winning
absolutely and then that if CNN goes
moderate and actually that's reporting
the news hey I'll give them I'll give
them credit we gotta cheer on when they
do good stuff now to be honest I don't
think they will but is that just they'll
have to they won't make money that's the
best part the right-wing grift at the
left complaint about all the time we
mentioned the other day business people
are going explain this you make money
doing this this gives you money uh yeah
let's invest in that
I was thinking it's like the victory of
a cultural battle which isn't really
Victory it's winning a battle but what
is the overall War score goal here like
what's the cultural Freedom personal
responsibility
people saying is up to me to work hard
to live a better life and make a better
future for my kids it's people saying
I'm not going to demand the government
pay my bills I'm going to do my best
it's not about what my government can do
for me but what I can do for my
government we got to look out for
corporations what was it saying okay
it's not about your country because
government's a bad word yeah government
corporations that take that message of
individual responsibility and highlight
it on a show for the entire world to
watch like slaves to like laud so that
that if you've seen a black there's a
black mirror episode where they do stuff
like that
um they will try and Co-op the message
of individual liberty as well and put it
on a pedestal course you have to call up
any message that Services them and that
people are willing to pay for yes really
that simple correct Uncle Yoda says Ian
I need you to wear a wizard suit for
Halloween anyways y'all doing a great
job I'm so into that yeah
Murph tries DIY says does anyone recall
when Dr Chris Martinson said they'd be
using lockdowns for climate change
Pepperidge Farm remembers
insert name here says NorCal here Tim
don't forget that chairman Newsom also
banned the sale of fuel powered
generators and that motorcycles are
included in the van amazing man I saw a
video of somebody trying to power up
their electric car with an oil generator
and it's just like
I probably should I I don't want to uh
give away too much but we're working on
a vlog episode script based on Green
Technology failures so like the electric
car have to be plugged into a generator
stuff like that we have some funny gags
planned for it
but that's there's a there's a an image
going viral right now of a giant a Tesla
plugged into a gas generator or a diesel
generator
amazing unbelievable yeah I believe it
salty duckling says y'all should do a
doc miniseries with the daily wire
called how we got here cover the left
and rights perspective of the event
leading up to today's political climate
so we have a resource to show those we
are trying to save
it all gamer games
oh man gamergate was what 10 years ago
geez don't say that yeah I wasn't paying
attention when that happened five years
ago no you were like 12. it's not paying
attention but I was still like in my
little bubble my little kid bubble yeah
I was literally 12. yeah I was not
concerned about it you're not a joke for
real that's awesome were you following
it gamergate when it happened a little
bit
yeah I saw you know like uh Sargon Carl
Benjamin and like chew on ahead how I
met how I found out about him yeah but I
didn't know too much about it I did know
that these companies were enacting this
policy stuff because I was working for
them you know
they were getting woke going broke yeah
Ryan Miller says missed the live show
celebrating my first birthday as a
father as a father but a late birthday
gift to myself with a shout out to
little Jackson Gilligan
Jackson Gilligan yes fatherhood
good good good San OT says sanoti says
bad thing is now on the Chrome extension
store bad thing so bad thing it was the
extension idea we had where basically
you take negative words for the right
like fascists and just this bad thing
I looked that up now it's a great idea
disrupting all the cultural institutions
you install the extension it replaces
all the words with bad things well CNN
would just be like bad thing bad thing
bad thing bad thing yeah pretty much
Donald Trump likes bad thing and wants
bad thing to happen hi bad things
straight up we want good things yeah
that's Sheamus's joke by the way yeah I
hope Sheamus made it has he not done it
yet I don't know
unsolicited says Crowder is sharing all
of his parodies on Spotify for free this
week maybe we can make another cultural
impact by downloading seasons of trump
I saw that I just wanna I just want to
tell everybody it's a lot it's it's
for the the big commentators it's not
very difficult to get on these charts as
long as you do it properly you got to
make a good song obviously but uh
it's not as hard as people realize you
know one of the things I think we're
seeing is these uh these book publishers
are going to commentators and and you
know political figures and saying can we
do a book with you because your brand
will market and sell this book in a big
way it's a brand that's what you got to
do we got to do with music we'll just go
around to every person and get him a
song there you go it's true and it
doesn't have to be like overtly
political like Tom McDonald and like the
Bryson Grays like your song wasn't and
that's I think a beautiful thing about
it because it gives us a better view of
just not being political all the time
and everything but that's why they're so
pissed off right so like the political
stuff doesn't bother them because they
know where to put it and it's easy to be
like hey look how far right that is yeah
but when the song so like only everyone
is just a love and pain song So when
regular people start hearing that we're
getting shazams meaning people are
hearing it and then wondering what it
isn't playing it those regular people
being are falling into our sphere of
influence and it's pulling it away from
the cultural institutions like he has a
podcast
and that's what they said you see The
Daily Beast article no they said that
I'm trying to lure people into my right
wing right wing world the alt-right
pipeline with
I told Sheamus because he's got to do a
cartoon where I have like a pipe and I'm
like bopping about and tooting and like
people are following me and like
marching into the GOP convention oh my
gosh people are just like yeah that's
exactly what's happening sailing down
the river on a raft that'd be awesome
while you're playing the flute so I want
to say for the cast Castle Vlog
um it's if we I think we put the full
thing on YouTube we'd probably get
banned for it because Ian's running for
Union president and then something
happens at 3am it's really good it's
crazy not based on real events it's just
right it's fictional purely
Chris is amazing he is like his like his
debut I mean for a while but he's really
good Ian was running for Union president
against Chris and you know everybody
voted but there are employees who don't
work here so we had to wait for the
absentee ballots right distance
I bet everyone buddy can figure out what
happens next in the show so crazy
but it was a free and fair election yeah
and then we have a cameo from James
Lindsay who sword fights Roberto Jr
that's on YouTube I love it right on the
cast Castle YouTube channel right now if
you want to see James yeah it's funny
because he was like actually showing us
how to do sword sword fighting because
James literally knows how to sort really
yeah
he's got to be prepared you know
hey man
War comes we don't know what weapons
we'll have is the thing is it true
Philip Reed says Tim talking about
making a tween pop song reminded me of
spose and his song pop song which was
about the big labels telling him he
can't make what he wants and that he
needs to make this instead you know that
song Love Song by Sara Bareilles yeah
you know the story of that yeah I'm
gonna write you a love song yeah like I
guess the story is the label said Write
a Love Song it sells and she was like I
don't want to and they're like well
that's what sells so then she wrote I'm
not gonna write you a love song because
you asked for it or whatever blew up
yeah yup stick to your guns that's right
yep
all right Denny decibel says Amala have
you come across David Barton and the
wall Builders Museum if so what do you
think if not will you look up them up I
will look them up never heard of him
David
Pizza makes my belly hurt says my aunt
works for the DNC came home from DC for
a week we started talking and said you
need to work on your white privilege I
looked her dead in the eye trying to
hold in laughter we're from Syria
amazing what a conflict yeah
Paul Jones says in reference to your
comment about the left-hating mixed-race
people I can 100 confirm I'm biracial as
well and I'm always called an Uncle Tom
because I don't say America is the worst
but that's like this is one of the
things that really bothers me they're
always like oh you won't see America's
the works then you're an extreme
opposite like it's to make you feel
ashamed and move closer to their point
by pushing you in the direction of the
extreme anything that falls outside of
it it's All or Nothing always like it's
not even who you're a republican it's
like oh so you're an extremist right
waffle Sensei says the left only shows
the straw man crazy people on the right
and the right only shows the straw man
crazy people on the left it's orienting
people to believe that everyone else is
polarized and there is no middle how do
we beat that thoughts false
um I do think it's true
um to a great degree but the left is
it's the rule and the right it's the
exception many people on the right only
show The Craze on the left all of the
prominent lefties only show or lie about
the people on the right
so you know for example we've given
praise to several people like Kyle
Kolinski and you know crystal ball for
instance were fans and Jimmy Dore as
well highlighting Jimmy dorsing I think
is a great example of showing someone
who's on the left who has socialist
policies but calls out what what is
false and wrong Jimmy's an awesome dude
that and and you know well but I guess
we're middle of the road I suppose but
uh Tucker Carlson has antifa on his show
he used to have a lot more a lot more
lefties Stephen Crowder routinely tries
to debate these individuals not the
craziest The prominent figures they
won't do it they won't yeah yeah we
recently reached out to Anna kasparian
of The Young Turks she was talking about
crime in this massive Spike that's
happening we're like I gave her praise
for it I same here and we were like we
could have some common ground I know we
don't normally agree would you want to
come on and talk about an issue that we
can find common ground on she goes on
The Young Turks I hate prageru they're
disgusting they're garbage I wouldn't go
on their show no matter how much they
pay me it's ridiculous that's crazy yeah
Dennis will really balanced guy he's
kind of like kind of a he is all around
I don't know a holistic dude but they
love to villainize him they love to
villainize him because he just fits the
bill you know old white man that's all
it is
Red Dragon Emperor says didn't get to
say this last time but Cali would not
benefit from nuclear power due to a
drought nuclear plants require one
billion gallons of water per day
um is that it's fresh water if it is the
north of California has fresh water it's
the South that doesn't so
they could do it I guess
yeah yeah that makes sense that seems
like a lot of water yeah I don't know
about a billion a billion seems like a
lot
um but I'm not an expert so I'm not
going to tell you wrong I will say
that's it's the cooling system I mean
water comes in we use water pressure you
probably couldn't do salt because you'd
get salt deposits yeah and you need a
constant stream okay yeah yeah makes
sense
yeah unless they can do like a
self-contained system that the steam
goes in like an air conditioner or
something like that and then the salt
melts and they use the salt the liquid
salt as a heat storage device
all right Ted scannon says love seeing
amla here and and that girl can sing Oh
yeah this may be off topic but uh but
you should bring her in on a song cheers
everyone that's awesome I sing and play
guitar yeah
yeah I don't know if you know
I would love to I do write music so yeah
that'd be let's do it yeah well let's
let's uh what do you want to do you want
to do like dance pop like you know
Britney Spears maybe Elton John maybe no
I'm just kidding man
most the top music is usually like dance
and Hip-Hop because it's club music
that's easily played we could do that I
just want to make it
I mean Pop I like country music I love
just like any good strong ballad all
these Jazz I love everything everything
you want to write a song about your dog
and your pickup truck hell yeah brother
all right Mark giodetti says Tim will be
too afraid to read this oh and I know he
wrote that because he knew I would read
it
to you yeah Ian speaks nothing but
nonsense he should learn to talk a lot
less TC he tricked me because he wanted
me to say that
but Ian had a bunch of 20s tonight so
careful with the all or none rhetoric
doesn't usually I I gotta say though the
one in the the rolling ones and 20s was
spot on yeah that means two extremists
for me I need more sevens in my life but
you do but that will be your crazy
100-sided
one over 20 and everyone's like that's
actually a good point like sometimes Ian
Nails it like wow I gotta wait for my
moment and then either come in hot and
slice through it like butter or I crunch
on the surface
Frieza says 38 000 people watching in
this video isn't trending not listed on
any lives and not the top search for Tim
Poole damn makes me feel like a real
hipster you know yeah we have this cool
thing going on but no one knows
the 11th I think the last I checked was
the Tim castile's the 11th biggest
entertainment live podcast on YouTube no
big deal and the 16th most super chatted
or maybe the other way around I think
it's the 11th most I'm not sure it's one
I don't know it's top performing huge
yeah so in terms of live performance
like we are the biggest like like the
11th biggest or whatever or 16th biggest
and then it's like but we're competing
against like you know anime waifus and
things like that so in terms of a real
sit-down human conversation podcast I
think we are the biggest live
yeah I'm not sure probably uh but live
when it comes to like so here's another
another issue episode per episode we're
not the biggest but it's because we do
five episodes per week many other
podcasts do one per week and they'll get
a million hits in that one week whereas
we get you know like 10 million or
something per week but it's split up
against all the other episodes right
yep so so if we did one per week all
those use it concentrate and we jump in
the I wonder if politics is the wrong
path I mean I know you you study it
during this entertainment show yeah it
is entertainment I try and make it
entertainment personally
um but we have things like EU riots in
the title of this video so that's
probably why it's not being shown and
trending and stuff and if we were just
talking about like Ally mcbeal's butt in
crap culture crisis exists for that
reason yeah
pop culture crisis is not trash no I
don't like talking about ali mcbeal's
butt like Brett's a genius anything he
does is good so I think part of it is
like if we only Chase like how can we
say trending and how can we do this
we're also feeding the exact same you
know comply with what YouTube wants yeah
like I'm really grateful that we're able
to talk about things that we're all
interested in but also not have to be
like well we can't talk about that
because like then we won't Trend or
whatever like I'm grateful that this has
grown past that point because I'm sure
in the beginning it was extremely
helpful to trend I mean it's a big deal
the show started off as more
entertainment it got more political
because politics became pop culture
right but uh this show is still and
always has been listed as an
entertainment not not news and politics
and that's because we bounce around on
cultural issues it's it's cultural
politics so it's tough you know I don't
know and it's tough to ignore crazy [ __ ]
in the world like it's happening and if
someone doesn't talk about it that's a
big problem but I I think you know
there's a question we had about whether
it's news or entertainment and that news
would be less jokey less trolley less
silly and very straightforward and very
stodgy like NPR podcasts would be a news
podcast
so you know I I this is more
conversational more entertainment than
personality driven yeah rather than news
driven yeah because I because I think if
we if we went if we labeled ourselves as
news we'd probably be the top news
podcast but it's like oh you know
like we don't like labels well it's it's
just that you listen to like the New
York Times Daily News brief and I'm like
that's a news podcast yeah you know the
like today in the news this is what
happened it's like oh well John I talked
to somebody and they said this it's like
where you know we say silly things and
if you I feel like I contrast a lot with
like the work that we do and The
Newsroom side of things where we try to
be really accurate and devoid of like
opinion we try to present things whereas
this show is more fluid and has it has a
different purpose and people come to it
for a different experience right it's
like daily wire has their journalism but
they have their personalities you know
all right let's read some more Buck
nukel says Tim there's a Democrat County
official here in Vegas who is who is
being accused of stabbing a journalist
in front of his home the journalist had
ousted him by the way rip Jeff German I
saw that story dude crazy right I did
not see that yeah times over there
Augusto mimoshay says a well-trained
horse won't move if you just set the
lead of their Bridal on the ground
because they've been trained that it
hurts to pull on wow yeah they're like
elephants yep
it's really funny uh like I don't want
to say too much but some of the
reactions from these journalists they're
just really really angry that uh Pete
Parada is succeeding
he's so good well Outsiders and people
who push back on the authority you know
I'll put it this way if you're somebody
who is really really angry that you were
forced to get the vaccine for your job
and then you find out other people are
succeeding and they didn't you're
probably really angry yeah that's fair
you're alive but what I had to do it why
don't they have there's that video of
the guys in the store and he's like is
anybody else mad that we have to wear
masks and she won't that's exactly it
yeah feel for like a generation of
people that are about to figure out what
it means to take an experimental
medicine and there's gonna be another
level of compassion that we need well
there's a there's a lot of things uh
let me just go back in time to
thalidomide it was that's right yeah yep
yeah you know that yeah yeah their birth
defects in kids it was like a an
anti-nausea medicine I only bring that
up to say one simple thing the best we
can do is find doctors that we trust yes
so my recommendation to people is if
you're having issues and you don't trust
your doctor you but just find a good one
and like experimental medicine this is
what I get don't like about covet is
that it two weeks to slow the spread
that was the experimental moment is it
going to kill Humanity are we going to
be bleeding out of our eyes like the
stand and we weren't like this and then
but for whatever reason they went
forward and pushed experimental medicine
anyway and I'm like
we had we did the shutdown to find out
yeah and we have to flatten the curve
you don't understand slow the spread
whatever flatten the J I'd really stand
by my comparison to Pavlov's dog like
they wanted to push as many buzzwords
that will elicit an immediate response
from people no matter what the issue is
they'll just go back to these
catchphrases so that you will comply and
at this time they put out these news
articles in the New York Times like the
Earth is healing and a lot of people
predicted they'll do the same thing for
climate change and it looks like that's
where we're going so let's read a
different article that's like the family
is healing because they're allowed to
spend time together again there you go
interesting Matthew stockhausen says
just wanted to say today is my daughter
Camilla's first birthday in the past
year she has been the perfect angel only
issue was an RSV scare when she was
three months old and was hospitalized
for three days smiling the whole time
too fair not her fault all right happy
birthday
someone Johnny Hixson gave us a big red
thumbs up well all right I love it yes
brag about their kids I think it's so
cute adorable yeah Pablo papano says
sounds like AOC regrets not being
married and having kids it does doesn't
it she's getting on that train isn't she
she no she can't because she's a
feminist that's right
narrative she can I don't want to be too
mean to feminist but like you know what
I do think that there is this like am I
making the right decisions and I think
it has to do with policy but I do think
the the article is interesting she says
like that it was her partner who was
like I want to get married by the end of
2022 and she was like I don't know how I
feel about that but I don't know that
she could have told this article as like
the head of feminism you know yeah I
really want to get married I hope you
propose I wanted her to propose three
years ago this is exactly what I talked
about when I say I think she's about to
get red pilled because she's about that
age she's about my age and she's
probably like oh yeah I should really
have a family right about now but there
was a story I saw earlier a study came
out saying that having kids makes you
more conservative on all these different
issues and I'm like yes surprise
surprise people are no longer in favor
of abortions for the most like many
people lose their favorite favorability
towards abortion when they have kids yep
and then there's a lot of women who are
like contemplating it had their kids
said wow I'm really glad I didn't do
that yep it's the weirdest thing that
it's like
there's like these laws that say if a
woman wants to get an abortion someone
has to counsel them on this stuff
because so many women have their kid and
then are grateful that they did yeah
that it's really creepy that you have to
try and stop someone from explaining
that to them like why if they don't want
to have an abortion because someone made
an argument let them not have the
abortions yeah what did Elizabeth Warren
say she said like the these uh crisis
pregnancy centers are torturing women is
what she referred to it as I think
that's Insanity
you take everything that's happening
right now from the Democrats on the left
and the end result is less people so
whether you want to believe there's a
conspiratorial depopulation agenda
doesn't matter intent is irrelevant
their actions are leading to it they
sterilize their kids they abort their
kids they advocate for not having kids
at all and now they're cutting the
electricity and they want to get rid of
fossil fuels like all of that will
result in less food less people less
babies well when you hear these
conversations with people being like Oh
I'm choosing not to have children or I'm
gonna you know maybe formula shortage
one of the things they say is like I
don't think I could do it how could I
afford it how could I find for like yeah
I would be stressed too if I didn't
think I had I was resourceful enough to
figure it out you know like their told
to put their needs over everyone else's
and then also it seems like it's
impossible to even take care of yourself
or at least that's what they're told
yeah and it could understand the
campaign that's going on yeah yeah 100
percent
all right let's see where we are with
some uh Paul longam says you should
watch season two of Legion as a spin-off
of X-Men just for the cold opens they
talk about psychology and what does that
say phycology and a lot of the cold
opens talk about how you can uh about
talk about you can see happened in real
life oh cool interesting like
psychedelics and stuff
so Kanan says AOC credit the Border
fence looking at an empty parking lot
she's an actress for her audience the
thing you kind of have to take into
account she did that at the border fence
she did the whole I thought I was gonna
die on January 6 when she wasn't in the
building tax question tax the rich dress
did the tax the rich dress uh she cried
about the state of where her grandmother
was living in Puerto Rico without
helping her there's like so many things
that have sort of lumped up as far as
her being pretty dramatic that's true
waffle Sensei says do not accept them
not including your YouTube views every
other artist in the world promotes their
own material not everybody likes every
song but the people bought your music
the issue is
so we we haven't got an official
response yet but um before we we we we
we made sure that we were doing
everything properly so that they could
not try and exclude us and we got
um some responses from the official
tracking companies saying like here's
what you got to do and you're good to go
and we're like all right and now they're
like well it wasn't uploaded properly in
a way that we can actually track the
data so and then I'm like okay we'll
self-report right how else was reported
before the internet yeah why can't I
just give you the document here's our
analytics here's the data from the back
end and that should be enough they might
say yes so that's why I'm not I'm not
I'm not you know look
we did this totally independently with
no idea what we were doing it's entirely
possible that we just screwed up fine
whatever that's fine you know the next
time you put out is going to be even
bigger than it is what it is I'm not I'm
not going to start this by going to war
before we have a chance to like
you know basically push this through the
fact that we've made the charts already
is like fine exclude YouTube we'll
figure it out but we're already there
every song we put out will end up
charting period and that's going to be I
mean that's it's kind of a crazy thought
to be honest yeah really what does that
say for the state of the music industry
right now either we're really great or
something's really wrong I just I mean
look for a lot of people a lot of the
big established mainstream music artists
they always chart always but most music
you'll listen to most of it never charts
and that's that's the crazy thing to me
that like a lot of the songs that I'm
really into uh the bands that I like
like you know uh well I'm not gonna name
any bands because I don't want to talk
about their their analytics and stuff
like that but they they very few songs
actually make it to the charts they just
put out a ton of Music people find it by
the albums and then over a long period
of time they make money off of it right
because charting is about like a small
finite period of time and how many views
you get in that moment or buys you get
in that moment right so it's like sales
and also streams is like different
charting methods so the Hot 100 is like
just the best
I think if they included our YouTube
views we would have hit the Hot 100
mm-hmm based on the other uh other bands
that were there and the comparable
metrics I think so like we sold better
than a lot of bands that are high up
right but obviously we wouldn't do
better than the club music that's
getting like 100 million plays or
something like that but that's whatever
the the top albums sell like hundreds of
thousands but I think the top
alternative album sold like 50k which is
kind of crazy what the way it works is
you get six months of pre-orders then
all those pre-orders drop your your
opening week and they're counted as your
first week sales which is total BS
that's nonsense you know what I mean
like you release the album how many
albums did you sell well for whatever
reason they say you can six months in
advance sell albums and that counts as
the first week release so when you see a
band say like we sold 50 000 albums and
it's like yeah over six months Right
congratulations I mean it used to they
sell way more back in the day now they
don't I'm fairly confident actually I
will say this I know for a fact that if
we did a pre-order on our album with a
six month lead time we'd probably hit
like the billboard 200 at the top we'd
probably sell a couple hundred thousand
without the amount of sales we already
have that's without listening they're
just buying it because they have faith
that it's going to be awesome or does it
like do they get a a sample of the song
or something before that no I don't know
people just so you know what I'll just
I'll just tell you guys we sold 12 500
songs in one week that's number two that
is this so if you can sell 12 520 some
odd songs in one week you will be number
two in digital did you get who got
number one I was Britain Elton John and
Brittany how many they sell did you get
that number based on the metrics I think
they probably sold 25 to 30. okay
they're some of the most famous
musicians in the world yeah I mean it's
a lot first song post um conservatorship
yeah if if you're uh uh a new artist
like selling 12 500 songs it's not an
easy task to do you know and and so I
really do appreciate everybody who
supported us but we have like we have
fans of the show we have fans of the
content we produce who supported us and
so it's a mix of General support
political support and people who
generally like like the music that we've
produced but uh I will just say that if
that's the case of what we can pull off
and one week let's say we we sold an
album six months in advance we have 24
weeks yeah we'd have a top charting
album I don't want to do that though I
don't want to sell songs without them
being out that's why I thought the
pre-order stuff is so dumb yeah like
we're gonna put out a song and I think
three weeks from now or that's that's
the plan we're waiting to hear back from
our industry guys so we can make sure
they can't exclude anything at this
point I guess people like the song they
can order sign up for the next one get
on the pre-order list for the next one
that's right
all right we'll just uh we'll grab uh
one more here
fleeting floating feather says Tim sing
punch a Nazi what a really great song
it was a parody of uh Paparazzi by Lady
Gaga by Chris Reagan and he took the
video down oh wow and so yeah exciting
violence he took it down because
um
I think the the reason is that he's
scared of the left and bowed out and try
to get away from the culture war or
something like that that's what it felt
like I didn't like that punch a Nazi
movement but that's and then he was
making fun of it he was mocking the idea
that to the left everyone's a Nazi and
then I guess some leftists told him that
he was helping Nazis so he said okay and
he took the video down crazy it was a
great song it was a killer you don't
punch them that's my friends yeah if you
haven't already you can check out our
music on Spotify search for timcast and
there's a two formal official songs will
of the people and only ever wanted with
several more to come we've got uh Bright
Eyes we've got um what do we got I think
we're calling it lockstep because
genocide is not a good marketing term no
we've got eyes of advice we've got a
million to one
um a lot of these songs you can already
see like because we played we jammed
them before words in a book all of these
things are getting ready for release so
thank you all so much for the support
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel head over to timcast.com become
a member we're gonna have a members only
show coming up you can follow me at Tim
cast IRL you can follow the show at Tim
Castile you can follow me at timcast I'm
alive do you want to shout anything out
oh yeah you can uh check out my stuff by
typing in omelette and Obi on any
platform I know it's a mouthful but you
can try uh also I'll be at prageru.com
if you worried about censorship so we'll
be cool I'm Hannah Claire brimlow I'm a
writer for timcast.com you should go
there every day and click on the recap
you can follow me on Instagram at
hannahclar.b and I'm Ian Crossland get
me Ian crossland.net again check out
cast Castle on timcast.com sign up it's
over on the left you click it episode
three
happy to do it happy to see you bye
that's right cast Castle is not the only
other show we have we also have pop
culture crisis which I was supposed to
be on today but I went and got my cast
changed we're all signing it look it's
really awesome I have oh you can't even
see it oh I want to show everything
um everybody's signing it so I will be
on tomorrow on pop culture Crisis 3 to 5
p.m eastern time you guys can follow me
on twitterminds.com that's our patch
Lids as well as sourpatchlets.me
somebody asked where's the video game oh
in production we actually play it fairly
often downstairs because the development
version is available and uh it's a it's
a collaboration with Sheamus so it's uh
I guess it's a freedom freedom Tunes
video game basically it's it's all
Freedom style super dope yeah and the
story is amazing and it's like passively
political but the character you play is
not political and it's like I don't want
to say too much maybe we'll come up with
a marketing plan for what we can
announce about the gaming shows we've
shown off some of it already on the Vlog
and on Instagram where it's like your
little guy and you're you know in a
skyscraper so it'll be fun anyway thanks
for hanging out head over to timcast.com
we'll see y'all all over there in about
an hour and uh thanks for hanging out
bye